J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez, vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut tout le monde, j'espère que vous allez bien. Comme promis, voici un épisode que j'ai enregistré en mai dernier avec Alexandra Masciantonio,
une chercheuse française actuellement en post-doc à l'université de Maastricht et qui travaille sur la question des réseaux sociaux et de la santé mentale.
Vous savez que j'aime beaucoup la, la psychologie sociale et c'est justement son domaine académique, le prisme à travers lequel elle se penche sur ces questions.
Un grand merci à Olivier Klein pour avoir organisé cette rencontre et je vous souhaite une bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Alexandra Masciantonio. Bonjour Alexandra.
Bonjour.
On est ici ensemble parce que tu travailles en psychologie sociale, tu es post-doc à l'université de Maastricht
et tu travailles donc sur les réseaux sociaux, à travers donc plusieurs prismes, notamment la question du bien-être, la question de l'engagement politique, la question du cyberharcèlement.
Donc ça fait beaucoup de,
beaucoup de façons différentes de regarder un même sujet. Donc la, la première question que j'ai envie de te poser, c'est qu'est-ce qui t'a amené à travailler sur les réseaux sociaux en particulier dans, dans ton travail en tant que,
psychologue social ?
Je sais pas si on dit ça comme ça.
On peut dire ça comme ça.
Quand j'ai fait mes études de psychologie, en fait, je voyais
mes enseignants qui nous parlaient de beaucoup de thématiques différentes et je me suis rendu compte que, on avait beau essayer de comprendre... parce que
quand on fait de la psychologie, on essaie de comprendre comment les êtres humains pensent, qu'est-ce qu'ils ressentent et qu'est-ce qui peut affecter tout ça.
Et quand on fait de la psychologie sociale, ce qui est ma discipline, on s'intéresse vraiment à comment les situations sociales peuvent affecter la manière dont on pense, dont on se comporte et ce qu'on ressent.
Et ce que je me rendais compte en fait, c'est qu'on travaillait jamais sur les situations en ligne, notamment sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et moi, je me rendais compte à quel point dans mon entourage, autour de moi, les réseaux sociaux, ça avait une place considérable
et je comprenais pas en fait pourquoi on se posait pas la question de nos comportements en ligne en fait, de comment les réseaux sociaux pouvaient nous affecter.
Et en fait très tôt, quand j'étais déjà en master, j'avais déjà envie de travailler sur cette thématique et j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir continuer durant mon doctorat et après.
Ok, ok. Et donc, en même temps, on peut comprendre que ce soit un sujet relativement récent dans le temps.
Bien sûr.
Et donc ton master, c'était en 2016 à peu près, c'est ça ?
C'est ça, oui.
Oui. Et même en 2016, alors que les réseaux sociaux avaient déjà à peu près dix ans à ce stade, même en 2016, la littérature, ça restait assez, assez léger ?
Je pense que c'est plutôt que les chercheurs parlent des recherches qu'ils, qu'ils font en fait. C'est juste que les chercheurs qui m'entouraient ne travaillaient pas forcément sur les réseaux sociaux.
Il y avait déjà des recherches, mais effectivement, de manière générale, les recherches sur les réseaux sociaux, elles ont commencé dans les années 2010.
Pourtant, LinkedIn et Facebook, c'est plus début des années 2000. Mais c'est vrai que, on va dire la première recherche souvent qui marque les travaux sur les réseaux sociaux date de 2008.
Donc c'est vraiment assez récent. Après, de manière générale, les chercheurs se sont intéressés très tôt aux effets des technologies, aux effets de tout ce qui est environnement médiatisé.
Et il y a des recherches qui datent des années 80 sur, sur, bien sûr, la télévision. On a des recherches sur les mails, on a des recherches sur tous les environnements numériques qu'on a, voilà, qu'on a depuis, depuis des, des années.
Ok. Et donc, la, la, ce qu'on entend régulièrement quand on parle de, voilà, de questions de psychologie, questions de réseaux sociaux, c'est, voilà, les, alors, les mots qui reviennent souvent et qui moi me font un petit peu
me gênent un petit peu, c'est les mots comme narcissisme.
Quand on va parler des, des réseaux sociaux, on va, on va beaucoup se poser la question du, du bien-être, de la comparaison avec les autres.
Est-ce que, est-ce que c'est, c'est là-dessus que tu as travaillé ? La question du bien-être, la question de la comparaison avec les autres ?
Oui, oui. C'est, c'est des questions que j'ai abordées durant mon doctorat notamment et sur lesquelles je continue à travailler.
Mais, si ça peut te rassurer, j'ai pas travaillé sur le narcissisme.
Ça va alors. On peut, on peut continuer cette interview.
Mais donc oui, mais parlons-en. Donc le, la question du bien-être sur les réseaux sociaux, on a notamment pu entendre parler de, de l'impact négatif de, de Facebook, entre autres choses, sur
la santé mentale pendant le, le COVID.
Alors évidemment, il y a plusieurs plateformes différentes qui ont plusieurs impacts différents sur la, sur la santé mentale.
Donc parlons un peu de tout ça. Question super vaste et super bateau pour commencer : est-ce que les réseaux sociaux sont une source de mal-être et de, de... ont un impact négatif sur la santé mentale de manière générale ?
Je commence vraiment de façon très très vague. On va, on va devenir plus précis après.
Ben, je vais répondre par une réponse très vague aussi. On sait pas.
On sait pas, OK.
La vérité, c'est que souvent, la vision sociétale des réseaux sociaux est très négative. On peut voir beaucoup de documentaires sur Netflix, par exemple.
On a beaucoup d'articles de journaux qui nous disent finalement que les réseaux sociaux vont détruire nos vies, que ça rend malheureux, qu'il faut empêcher les adolescents d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux, qu'on devient aliéné.
La vérité, c'est que dans le monde scientifique, on n'a pas de preuves suffisantes pour dire que les réseaux sociaux ont un impact vraiment négatif sur notre bien-être.
En fait, ça dépend tellement des situations. Mon point de vue à moi, c'est que les réseaux sociaux, ça reste un autre contexte social en fait.
C'est-à-dire que tout ce qui se passe dans la vie réelle peut se passer dans les réseaux sociaux. Quand on parle... pas tout à fait. Alors en fait...
Il faut nuancer.
Voilà, je peux nuancer. C'est juste que par exemple, si on parle de cyberharcèlement, le harcèlement existe dans la vie réelle, mais il va prendre des formes différentes en ligne,
tout simplement parce qu'on peut être anonyme, on peut toucher quelqu'un, on peut, on peut par exemple avoir beaucoup plus de visibilité.
L'impact est plus important parce que ça se, on... quand on est harcelé à l'école primaire, même si ça peut avoir des effets délétères sur la santé mentale, ça reste dans une école primaire.
Il y a peut-être les dix enfants de la classe ou les vingt enfants ou les trente malheureusement, qui sont au courant. Quand on est sur les réseaux sociaux, ça peut rester à vie.
Il y a deux cent, trois cent personnes qui peuvent le voir, donc l'impact est très différent. Mais c'est pas les réseaux sociaux qui nous poussent à harceler les autres.
Et c'est pas les réseaux sociaux qui nous confrontent à l'harcèlement, c'est aussi des comportements qui sont humains. Si on revient plus précisément sur le bien-être, si je ne suis pas trop longue dans la réponse.
Non, je t'en prie, je t'en prie.
Mais quand on est sur, quand on, quand on parle de la question du bien-être en fait, la vérité, c'est que ça va dépendre de tellement de facteurs qu'il est très difficile d'avoir une réponse définitive.
Déjà, ça va dépendre de l'âge.
Quand on parlait par exemple de la comparaison sociale, quand on est adolescent, on sait pas vraiment qui on est et du coup, on va se tourner beaucoup vers les autres pour se comparer, pour savoir si ce qu'on fait, c'est bien, si c'est normal.
Et le problème, c'est que les réseaux sociaux vont là avoir un impact beaucoup plus important sur les adolescents qu'ils ne vont l'avoir, par exemple, sur les adultes.
Quand on a quarante ans et qu'on utilise les réseaux sociaux, on a un regard, on a aussi un recul que n'a pas un adolescent.
Donc déjà, par exemple, l'âge, c'est très important.
Il y a aussi beaucoup de choses que de manière générale, on voit qu'il y a un effet négatif des réseaux sociaux, un petit effet négatif, mais par exemple, on n'arrive pas à dire si cet effet, il est vraiment important.
Alors en science, on essaie toujours de comprendre ça. Pour vous donner un exemple, dormir bien les nuits et prendre un petit déjeuner, ça a plus d'impact sur notre bien-être que les réseaux sociaux dans ce qu'on trouve dans la science.
Donc, c'est-à-dire qu'on trouve un impact négatif, il est tellement, tellement petit qu'en fait, est-ce que vraiment, ils détruisent nos vies ?
Mais il peut, je pense, avoir un impact...
Il peut.
Bien, bien plus important, voilà, dans les cas de cyberharcèlement, dans les cas de, oui, je sais pas, l'usage des réseaux sociaux quand on est en, en dépression, par exemple.
Exactement. Alors en fait, justement, c'est ça. C'est-à-dire que les premières recherches, elles montrent ce tout petit effet négatif.
Et nous, maintenant, les chercheurs, ce qu'on se dit en ce moment, c'est : il y a quelque chose qu'on loupe, en fait. Il y a quelque chose qu'on est en train de louper.
Donc ce qu'on essaie de regarder, c'est déjà effectivement la question de l'âge, c'est-à-dire qui utilise des réseaux sociaux.
Donc, il y a pas forcément que l'âge qu'on regarde. Il y a aussi des personnalités, des personnes plus anxieuses qui vont du coup plus être sensibles au contenu qu'ils voient sur les réseaux sociaux par rapport à d'autres.
Mais aussi, on va s'intéresser à la manière dont on utilise les réseaux sociaux. Est-ce que je vais simplement passer mon temps à scroller mon fil d'actualité, c'est-à-dire que je suis confronté à beaucoup d'images, par exemple, positives ?
Ou est-ce que je vais au contraire poster des vidéos, poster des photos ? Parce que là, il y a quand même un caractère actif, en fait, où on va créer des choses, on va, on va interagir beaucoup plus avec les autres.
Ok, très bien. Mais, mais donc, effectivement, différentes façons d'utiliser les plateformes. On peut être passif, on peut être actif, on peut créer du contenu, on peut juste y être confronté.
Mais je voudrais revenir sur quelque chose que tu as dit un petit peu plus tôt, comme quoi, donc, le harcèlement ou les expériences négatives sociales qu'on peut avoir,
sur les réseaux sociaux, on peut aussi les avoir en face à face.
La différence, je pense, c'est surtout le fameux, la fameuse notion d'algorithme où certains contenus vont être plus mis en avant, ils vont attirer plus de réactions et différents types de réactions, différents types d'émotions.
Et les algorithmes, en particulier celui de Facebook et peut-être aussi celui de TikTok, je ne sais pas, vont gérer leur flux sur base de ça.
Et ça, c'est une notion qui est quand même absente du, de, de la vie hors ligne en face à face. Donc, c'est une différence importante, il me semble.
Alors, je dirais oui et non. Alors, la première chose, c'est que, on a par exemple le phénomène d'echo chamber, chambre d'écho.
Oui, c'est ça.
Ce phénomène-là, en fait, est présent aussi dans la vie réelle. Souvent, on l'oublie. Enfin, je dis vie réelle pour opposer à réseaux sociaux, mais on comprend que la... Il y a pas de, il y a pas de vie en ligne et vie hors ligne.
En fait, la plupart du temps, ils sont mêlés, mais, pour, pour l'utilité d'aujourd'hui, je vais faire, je vais faire cette distinction.
Mais quand on est dans la vie réelle, on va soi-même se mettre... 'fin, c'est naturel, en fait. Donc le phénomène de chambre d'écho,
c'est que naturellement, on va avoir tendance, en tant qu'être humain, à s'entourer de choses qui vont dans le sens de nos opinions.
On en a besoin, on a besoin de cohérence. Donc, on a besoin à un moment donné de s'entourer des choses qui vont... on peut pas être tout le temps dans un environnement où tout le monde est contre nous.
C'est très fatigant. Et en tant qu'être humain, on a besoin de s'entourer de gens qui vont dans notre sens. Du coup, on le fait naturellement.
On va par exemple choisir des journaux qui sont dans le sens de nos opinions politiques. On va regarder des émissions à la télévision qui vont dans le sens de ce qu'on pense du monde aussi.
On va pas forcément regarder une série qui va à l'encontre de ce qu'on pense, etc. Donc, on le fait naturellement, mais sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est pas nous qui le décidons, c'est un algorithme qui le fait.
Du coup, sur les réseaux sociaux, on parle de filter bubble. Donc...
Bulle idéologique.
Voilà, bulle idéologique. Donc, c'est le même phénomène d'echo chamber, mais en ligne, mais qui est favorisé par les algorithmes.
Donc, effectivement, je suis d'accord que c'est beaucoup plus marqué en ligne, mais c'est ce que je disais, de naturellement, on va le faire de nous-mêmes.
Surtout, il y a beaucoup d'études qui montrent, par exemple, notamment avec les fake news, parce qu'on en voit beaucoup, que c'est pas parce qu'on nous montre une information qu'on va y prêter attention.
En fait, beaucoup de fois, le point de vue sociétal sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est ce qu'on appelle souvent un déterminisme psychologique, technologique, pardon.
C'est-à-dire, on a cette idée qu'on nous met une technologie dans les mains et forcément, elle va prendre le dessus sur nous.
Donc parce que l'algorithme nous dit : il faut regarder ça, forcément, ce qui se passe, c'est qu'on va aller dans le sens que l'algorithme ou l'algorithme veut nous emmener.
La réalité, c'est qu'on n'est pas attentif à tout ce qui nous arrive comme information. On n'est pas attentif à tout. C'est connu depuis longtemps, depuis la télévision, notamment avec les publicités.
Mais c'est-à-dire que même si notre algorithme va nous censurer les mêmes infos, ça veut pas dire qu'on va forcément s'y arrêter.
Et ça veut pas forcément dire qu'on va y être sensible ou que ça va nous affecter. Par contre, le problème, c'est que si ça nous affecte, là, ça peut avoir des effets délétères.
Je sais pas si j'ai répondu.
Mais oui, oui et non. C'est-à-dire que t'as notamment répondu sur la question de la bulle idéologique, voilà, je vais y arriver.
Mais je maintiens que l'expérience, quand on passe du temps sur Facebook, par exemple,
c'est celui que j'emploie le moins, mais de ce que je sais, le contenu auquel on est confronté va suivre donc une logique d'algorithme qui est vraiment spécifique aux expériences sur les réseaux sociaux, par opposition aux,
à la vie en face à face.
Oui.
Pour ne pas, pour ne pas dire la vie réelle. Et donc, et donc je reste surpris par ta, ta formule comme quoi c'est, il n'y a pas de différence fondamentale.
Alors je suis d'accord, effectivement.
Mh.
Alors, je dirais que ça dépend aussi du réseau social.
Oui.
Typiquement, sur Facebook, donc l'algorithme va décider de ce qu'on voit, mais ça reste des gens qu'on a dans notre...
C'est ça.
Ça reste nos amis.
Et encore.
Oui, de moins en moins.
Oui, voilà, de plus en plus confrontés à des, des contenus que nos amis ont, ont aimés ou voilà.
Exactement.
C'est pas forcément les choses que nous, on aurait envie de voir a priori.
Oui, exactement. En fait, c'est aussi parce que les premiers réseaux sociaux comme LinkedIn ou Facebook avaient ce truc où en fait, on allait se connecter à quelqu'un.
Seulement, il nous acceptait donc là et on voyait le contenu que les gens qui, avec qui on était amis avaient partagé.
Et dans un ordre chronologique, enfin, c'était très...
Exactement.
Il y avait très peu d'interventions de la part du, de la plateforme.
Le truc, c'est que plus les réseaux se sont avancés avec les nouveaux réseaux sociaux. Donc, on a eu Twitter qui était un, je vais pas dire le premier, mais un des premiers où là, pour le coup, Twitter, on voit du contenu de tout le monde,
même des gens qu'on suit pas.
Et là, du coup, c'est déjà très différent parce que là, l'algorithme...
donc en fait, la recherche, elle montre que les algorithmes ont des effets, donc certains algorithmes ont des effets plus importants que d'autres sur les individus, notamment Twitter.
Donc là, c'est plus sur, sur le phénomène de polarisation, mais notamment, par exemple, Twitter a un effet plus négatif que l'algorithme de Facebook.
Et ça, c'est simplement parce que du coup, sur Facebook, on reste quand même avec des gens qu'on a d'une certaine manière choisis ou en tout cas un entourage d'entourage.
Sur Twitter, c'est pas le cas. Et là, en fait, plus on avance dans les réseaux sociaux, on a de, en 2016, on a eu TikTok et là, on est encore sur une autre forme parce que TikTok, avec son fil d'actualité pour toi,
on a vraiment un algorithme qui va vraiment nous orienter vers des choses très précises.
Donc, est-ce que je peux dire que c'est de pire en pire ? Non, mais
je suis d'accord avec la remarque qu'il y a ce phénomène d'algorithme sur les réseaux sociaux qui est très difficile pour les chercheurs d'étudier parce qu'on n'a pas accès à ces algorithmes.
Exactement. Et donc du coup, on a beaucoup de mal en fait à, à, à tout simplement pouvoir travailler dessus et comprendre leurs effets.
Donc, je suis d'accord sur cette remarque. En fait, moi, ce que je voulais dire, c'est tout simplement que les réseaux sociaux vont pas forcément créer des nouveaux comportements humains.
Oui, c'est ça, oui.
C'était plus ça ma remarque.
Quand on parle d'interaction sociale.
Exactement.
De, de, entre deux individus ou un groupe d'individus, ça reste des mécaniques.
Donc voilà, pour moi, le fait qu'on puisse être, qu'on puisse ressentir de l'amour, de la haine, de la colère, ça reste des comportements humains.
Et pour moi, les réseaux sociaux sont un autre contexte. Donc un contexte qui effectivement a des modalités différentes, dont l'algorithme, dont l'anonymat, dont le fait de pouvoir parler à des personnes dans le monde entier instantanément.
C'est ça.
Et donc du coup, peut-être là, c'est un peu plus clair, je pense, comme ça.
Oui, tout à fait. Parlons alors de, comme tu viens de le faire, des, des spécificités de chaque plateforme. Qu'est-ce qu'on a remarqué en termes de, d'impact sur le bien-être qui soit spécifique à chacune de ces plateformes ?
Donc reprenons les principales, Facebook, Twitter. On peut parler d'Instagram, de LinkedIn aussi, j'aimerais bien.
Je pense que c'est un endroit assez particulier. Et de TikTok, sur lequel je passe trop de temps.
Il y a-- parfois, on cite aussi WhatsApp, mais je trouve ça très étrange de citer ça comme un réseau social parce que c'est,
c'est une application de messagerie, mais je pense que c'est employé différemment en Inde ou peut-être ailleurs dans le monde.
Alors effectivement. Alors pour WhatsApp, beaucoup de gens considèrent que c'est un réseau social, je ne le considère pas.
Oui.
Et dans la littérature scientifique, dans la communauté scientifique, de manière générale, on ne le considère pas comme un réseau social parce qu'effectivement...
Donc comment définir un réseau social ? Peut-être juste avant. Alors, il y a plein, plein, plein de définitions.
La plupart du temps, on a un profil, ce qui déjà est un peu manquant dans WhatsApp, même si on peut avoir un profil, mais c'est très différent d'un profil qu'on aurait sur les réseaux sociaux.
C'est vrai que maintenant, on peut faire des stories, on peut avoir un statut, mais-
C'est pour ça.
Mais personne n'emploie ça. C'est l'autre problème.
Normalement aussi, dans les réseaux sociaux, il y a l'idée de pouvoir consulter les connexions des autres. C'est-à-dire que par exemple, je peux regarder qui est connecté à qui.
Et il y a aussi cette idée de fil d'actualité. Et donc, c'est quelque chose qui est absent de WhatsApp.
Mais par exemple, Snapchat est des fois considéré comme un réseau social alors qu'il peut être aussi une application de messagerie.
Et donc du coup, il a un peu les deux rôles. Ça dépend.
Ouais, je comprends, ouais. Et on peut faire la même question sur TikTok et YouTube. Il n'y a pas vraiment de profil sur YouTube.
Il n'y en a pas vraiment non plus sur TikTok. Et pourtant...
Ah, je dirais que TikTok, mais juste débat la semaine dernière avec une collègue, donc il n'y a pas de réponse parfaite.
Pour moi, TikTok ressemble un peu dans le format quand même à Instagram, parce qu'on a notre profil avec les vidéos en dessous.
Oui, c'est ça.
Alors que c'est un tout petit peu différent sur YouTube. Mais de manière générale, YouTube et TikTok sont considérés comme des réseaux sociaux et je dirais que WhatsApp non.
Mais il n'y a pas de science parfaite de ce qu'est un réseau social. Des fois, on va avoir tendance à utiliser le mot médias sociaux qui est un peu plus large.
C'est très américain aussi, ouais, social media.
Exactement. Alors, médias sociaux, c'est vraiment plus large. C'est-à-dire que Wikipédia est un média social.
Ouais.
Voilà. En fait, c'est parce qu'on a commencé avec ce qu'on appelait le Web 1.0, puis on est passé au Web 2.0, c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus d'interactivité des utilisateurs.
Et du coup, Wikipédia, voilà. Exactement. Wikipédia rentre dans cette zone-là, mais c'est pour ça que j'aime bien des fois utiliser le terme de réseaux sociaux, c'est un peu plus spécifique.
Ouais. Bon donc reprenons donc sur les questions du bien-être et la spécificité de chaque plateforme. Donc commençons par-- on a beaucoup parlé de Facebook, parlons d'Instagram.
Qu'est-ce que, je vais réduire le focus sur les jeunes utilisateurs, en particulier les jeunes utilisatrices d'Instagram, qu'est-ce qu'on observe en termes d'impact sur le bien-être, en termes de comparaison avec les autres,
vis-à-vis d'Instagram ?
Alors, déjà, il faut juste préciser que la communauté scientifique, il y a un manque sur le fait qu'on compare très peu les réseaux sociaux.
Donc moi, c'est mon approche. C'est-à-dire que moi, dans mes travaux, je compare systématiquement les réseaux sociaux, mais c'est assez rare encore.
Ce qui fait que souvent, il y a des recherches sur les réseaux sociaux. Et la plupart du temps, ça veut dire Facebook.
Donc la plupart des recherches qu'on a dans la littérature scientifique portent sur Facebook, et on a encore très peu de recherches sur une comparaison de réseaux sociaux.
Cela dit, Instagram a quand même intéressé la communauté scientifique, donc là, je peux en dire un peu plus.
Alors en fait, c'est très particulier Instagram parce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle, donc sur tous les réseaux sociaux de manière générale, on a ce qu'on appelle un biais de positivité.
Ce qui fait que quand on va poster des choses sur les réseaux sociaux, on a tendance à poster des choses plutôt positives.
Assez rarement, on va poster une photo de nous en train de pleurer. Ça peut arriver, bien sûr, mais de manière générale, c'est plutôt positif.
Oui.
On montre les photos de vacances au ski, on montre les photos du chat tout mignon.
Exactement.
Et on ne montre pas, oui, les malheurs qui nous sont arrivés au travail ou dans les transports ou tout ça, ouais.
Alors, ou quand on le montre, c'est pour le sublimer ou le rendre artistique. 'Fin, il y a aussi de ça.
Alors, ce n'est pas le cas sur tous les réseaux sociaux, on en reviendra après, mais par exemple, ce n'est pas le cas sur Twitter.
On va dire que le biais de positivité, il est peut-être un peu plus, il est différent sur Twitter. Mais pour revenir sur Instagram, on a ce biais, c'est-à-dire qu'on montre des choses positives.
Ce qui fait que quand on va, donc quand on se compare aux autres, on peut se comparer de plusieurs manières.
La plupart du temps, on utilise deux termes en psychologie, ce qu'on appelle la comparaison ascendante et la comparaison descendante.
La comparaison ascendante, c'est le fait de se comparer à des personnes qu'on considère, entre guillemets, supérieures à soi.
C'est-à-dire des personnes que j'ai l'impression qu'ils réussissent bien mieux leur vie et qui sont bien plus heureux.
Oui.
Et la comparaison descendante, c'est se comparer à des personnes que l'on considère inférieures à soi, en tout cas des personnes où on a l'impression qu'ils ont moins bien réussi leur vie.
Le problème, c'est que comme l'information est principalement positive, la plupart du temps, la comparaison, elle est ascendante parce que tout est positif.
Donc on a-- ce n'est pas toujours le cas, mais on a souvent l'impression que les gens réussissent mieux que nous quand on va sur Instagram.
Et cette comparaison sociale ascendante, elle a plutôt des effets négatifs sur le bien-être, sur l'image du corps.
Pour les-- on parlait des jeunes filles, on montre quand même-- certaines études montrent que, parce que la pression mise,
sur les femmes et les jeunes filles, notamment pour avoir un corps qui rentre dans les idéaux sociétaux, même si les hommes sont aussi sujets à ce type de stéréotypes, mais de manière différente,
on arrive souvent sur Instagram à des effets plus négatifs pour les femmes et de manière générale, à cause de ce phénomène de comparaison sociale.
On a aussi le phénomène qu'on appelle d'objectivation. Donc c'est simplement le fait d'objectifier un corps, c'est se le représenter comme un objet.
On oublie qu'il y a une humanité derrière, tout simplement. Et sur Instagram, vu qu'on a souvent des poses, on a tendance à objectifier les corps d'autant plus.
Et il y a aussi des études qui montrent que vis-à-vis des jeunes filles, Instagram peut amener à plus d'objectivation.
Cela dit, il y a des recherches plus récentes qui montrent aussi qu'il n'y a pas forcément que des effets négatifs de se comparer à des gens qu'on co-
qu'on considère supérieurs à soi, mais il peut y avoir des effets positifs, notamment parce que les gens se sentent inspirés.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des gens qui vont voir ces éléments positifs et vont se dire : « J'ai vraiment envie d'y arriver » et ça va les motiver.
Alors qu'est-ce qui distingue les deux ? Qu'est-ce qui fait que quelqu'un voit quelque chose de positif ?
Est-ce que par exemple, voir un très beau, une très belle personne avec un très beau corps sur Instagram et se dire : « Ah, elle a eu une opération sur les lèvres pour avoir des lèvres toutes fines.
Ça m'inspire. J'ai envie d'aussi aller trouver son chirurgien en Turquie. » Est-ce que c'est de l'inspiration positive, ça ?
Est-ce que c'est à moi de juger si c'est positif ou pas ?
Non, mais est-ce que, non, mais est-ce que ça, ça répond aux critères que tu viens de poser ? C'est-à-dire, on trouve un exemple et on se dit : « Ah, moi aussi,
j'ai envie d'arriver à ce statut, à ce degré de beauté » ou je ne sais quoi, ouais.
Ça peut-- Le truc, c'est qu'en fait, quand on est chercheur, moi, je ne me pose pas la question, je n'ai pas
forcément cette question de moralité parce que si je la mettais en, si j'avais la moralité dans mes travaux, ils seraient plus neutres, même s'ils ne sont jamais neutres.
Mais ma question ne portait pas sur la moralité.
Mais
alors la question pour moi, c'est si la personne se sent mieux,
si ça l'aide à trouver un objectif à sa vie, que ça l'aide,
à se lever ce matin en se disant : « Bah voilà, ce truc que je n'aimais pas chez moi, mes lèvres, eh ben, je sais que maintenant, je vais mettre de l'argent de côté pour aller me payer cette opération.
» Moi, foncièrement, elle est plus heureuse. Donc, je dirais oui.
Et en même temps, ce complexe initial, peut-être aussi, trouve aussi peut-être sa source sur les réseaux sociaux.
Peut-être aussi. Alors après, on a aussi beaucoup, par exemple sur Instagram, les recherches ont plus été faites dans ce cadre-là, de tout ce qui est mouvement de beauty positive.
Et c'est plus sur ces recherches-là où des personnes ont réussi à s'accepter en se disant : « Ben, cette personne qui arrive à sortir de chez elle en bikini ou peu importe, ben moi, je me dis que je pourrais un jour y arriver.
» Donc c'est aussi dans ce sens-là. Et il y a aussi pas mal de recherches qui ont été faites sur tout ce qu'on appelle,
ouf, j'ai plus le terme du tout, mais c'est les motivations fitness, où là aussi des personnes se disent : « Ben voilà, j'ai envie d'aller faire du sport, j'ai envie de me sentir mieux dans mon corps.
» Et donc là, ça les motive. Donc c'est plus dans ce cadre-là que sur la chirurgie esthétique. Mais ça pourrait d'une certaine manière s'appliquer.
Mais c'est vrai que les recherches n'ont pas forcément été faites dans ce domaine-là. En fait, la vraie différence, c'est qu'est-ce qui fait que par exemple, quelqu'un voit une photo de quelqu'un,
qui est très en forme et se dise : « Ça me rend triste, j'y arriverai jamais, je ne me sens pas bien.
» Et quelqu'un d'autre qui va se dire : « Moi, j'ai envie d'y arriver. » C'est souvent est-ce que les personnes pensent qu'elles peuvent y arriver, en fait, tout simplement.
Et ça, ben ça dépend de l'estime de soi, parce qu'on peut voir quelqu'un qui a l'impression de mieux réussir que nous, mais se dire : « Mais je peux y arriver.
» Et on peut voir aussi quelqu'un qui réussit mieux que nous et se dire : « De toute manière, j'y arriverai pas. » Et on parlait tout à l'heure de la dépression.
C'est un très bon exemple parce que souvent quand on demande : est-ce que les réseaux sociaux, c'est un effet négatif sur la santé mentale ou sur le bien-être ?
On oublie que des fois, c'est aussi une stratégie pour faire face et que beaucoup de gens qui sont déjà malheureux ont tendance à passer beaucoup de temps sur les réseaux sociaux pour passer le temps, pour s'occuper, pour se changer les idées.
Parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que quand on va sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles on y va.
Le problème, c'est que vu que ces personnes sont déjà dans un état négatif, ça va faire qu'être un cercle vicieux. Et c'est ça aussi qui différencie quand je disais qu'il faut regarder qui utilise les réseaux sociaux.
Si on est déjà très mal dans sa vie, les réseaux sociaux, ça n'a pas forcément un effet positif. Par contre, si c'est quelqu'un qui est assez équilibré dans sa vie et qui a du recul, ça ne va pas forcément avoir un effet délétère.
Et c'est souvent pour ça qu'on trouve un effet qui est tout petit, parce qu'il va peut-être être très grand pour certaines personnes et peut-être absent pour d'autres.
Mais donc, effectivement, plein de profils différents qui peuvent aller sur, en l'occurrence, Instagram et avoir des expériences différentes selon le contexte.
Dans le cas d'Instagram, qu'est-ce qui amène les gens sur Instagram ? Qu'est-ce que les gens viennent chercher ?
La plupart du temps, alors, il y a quelques recherches dessus. Il y a déjà l'interaction sociale. Parler à ses proches, rencontrer des nouvelles personnes, c'est important.
Il n'y a pas que ça.
On a dit que justement, l'expérience sur Instagram, c'est plutôt passif.
Oui, mais par exemple, on peut voir des nouvelles de ses proches. Des fois, c'est juste pour se tenir au courant de ce que les gens font.
Voilà. Donc, il y a déjà cet aspect-là, social, ça reste un réseau social. Donc c'est forcément un aspect important. Mais il n'y a pas que ça.
Alors, sur Instagram, on a aussi
l'auto-documentation. Donc c'est un terme un peu... Mais il y en a certains qui considèrent Instagram un peu moins ces dernières années, mais comme un album souvenir, où en fait, on va poster des photos de choses qu'on a aimées dans notre vie.
Et c'est une sorte de vitrine aussi personnelle
parce qu'on garde ces souvenirs et puis après, on peut revenir. Ce qui est vraiment en train de changer, parce que de plus en plus, les jeunes générations, elles suppriment les photos sur Instagram, elles ne les gardent pas.
Ce qui était peut-être, c'est un peu old school maintenant de garder ses, 'fin, de garder sur Facebook ou Instagram les photos pendant des années, mais en tout cas, à une période, il y avait ça.
Il y avait aussi le fait de vouloir s'exprimer. Des personnes qui disaient que c'est un moyen aussi de pouvoir parler d'art, parler de cuisine.
Donc, il y a un moyen d'expression. Puis aussi le fait de vouloir, donc ce n'est pas tout le monde, mais certaines personnes, c'est aussi vouloir se sentir cool, entre guillemets.
Donc, il y a le fait aussi de vouloir montrer une belle image de soi. Le fait est que quand on va sur les réseaux sociaux, il y a de manière générale beaucoup de motivations différentes, mais il faut se dire que ça peut aussi booster.
C'est pour ça que je parlais aussi de manière d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux. Poster des photos positives de sa vie, d'une certaine manière, ça aide aussi à la voir de manière positive en fait.
Et donc du coup, ça peut-- C'est pour ça que je disais entre quelqu'un qui passe son temps à scroller et qui voit du contenu positif et qui se compare et quelqu'un qui poste ses photos...
Et qui se sent bien dans sa peau et qui reçoit du feedback positif, etc. Oui, c'est très différent, j'imagine. Mais donc, ok, donc ça, c'est pour Instagram.
Si on passe maintenant sur un tout autre public, par exemple celui de LinkedIn, est-ce que tu as eu l'occasion de travailler sur LinkedIn ou de lire des travaux sur LinkedIn ?
Alors un tout petit peu, mais bizarrement, c'est un réseau social qui a été globalement évité. Alors pourquoi ? Parce que c'est un réseau social professionnel.
Oui, bien sûr, par les chercheurs. Parce que c'est un réseau social professionnel. Donc souvent, on s'est dit que ce n'est pas pareil que Facebook, mais souvent parce qu'ils ont été créés.
Donc quand je m'intéresse, quand je dis que je compare les réseaux sociaux, je les compare par rapport à leur forme, leur architecture.
Ça veut dire quand on va sur un réseau social, il y a la manière dont le fil d'actualité est présenté, la manière dont on se connecte aux gens.
Est-ce que c'est réciproque ou non ? On en parlait avec les amis Facebook, par exemple. C'est un des premiers points et je les compare sur d'autres points.
Mais du coup, Facebook ressemble beaucoup à LinkedIn parce qu'ils ont été créés en même temps.
Dans les mécaniques, dans le...
Exactement. C'est-à-dire qu'on a aussi ce profil où on va pouvoir renseigner des tonnes d'informations, ce qu'on fait plus.
C'est-à-dire, par exemple, sur LinkedIn, on peut renseigner, bon, c'est un réseau professionnel, mais on peut renseigner les écoles qu'on a faites, on peut avoir des recommandations.
Sur Facebook, on peut renseigner est-ce qu'on est en couple, les écoles aussi qu'on a faites, etc. On ne fait plus ça. Sur les nouveaux réseaux sociaux comme TikTok, on ne va pas renseigner ou Instagram non plus.
Exactement. Et même Twitter pour le coup. Donc en fait, c'est des vieux réseaux sociaux avec une vieille structure tous les deux.
Et souvent dans la littérature, ce qu'on dit, c'est que c'est tous les deux des réseaux sociaux qui nous poussent à montrer une image très positive de nous.
Mais l'un est vraiment sur une image positive professionnelle et l'autre sur une image positive plutôt personnelle.
Et donc, LinkedIn, ce qui est vraiment intéressant, c'est que je pense que ces dernières années, il y a eu un vrai changement.
Les personnes sont de plus en plus actives. Ça devient un réseau social qui est vraiment incontournable.
Et la plupart du temps maintenant, pour les jeunes, en fait, les jeunes générations, c'est un peu comme Facebook, ils se sentent obligés d'y être.
Oui, il y a...
Une pression.
Oui, mais ne serait-ce qu'en termes de réseautage, en termes d'opportunités professionnelles, il y a un intérêt que ça amène quoi et que, oui, comme tu dis, assez indispensable.
Exactement. Ils ne vont pas-- 'fin, par exemple, Instagram, en soi, on peut ressentir une pression, mais elle est beaucoup plus légère.
Souvent, les jeunes générations, en tout cas dans les recherches, disent qu'ils ont envie tout simplement d'y aller. Ils ont envie d'aller sur TikTok.
Personne ne les oblige. Par contre, LinkedIn et Facebook, on les oblige à y être. Facebook pour la famille et LinkedIn pour le professionnel.
Donc, c'est des réseaux sociaux qui sont assez particuliers. Mais pour le coup, quand on parlait de biais de positivité, LinkedIn, on est là-dedans aussi.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est sur des réseaux sociaux où on essaye de montrer une image très positive. Et donc, quand je compare les réseaux sociaux, je m'intéresse aussi aux normes.
Donc tout ce que j'appelle normes, c'est les règles implicites, c'est-à-dire des choses, on sait qu'on doit le faire, mais personne ne le dit clairement.
C'est ça les normes.
Mais dans le cas de LinkedIn, précisément, donc, tu disais un biais de positivité très important. Au niveau du contenu qu'on remarque sur ce site, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi une
un type de contenu, un type de post, un type de message en particulier qui va être exprimé sur ce site-là ?
Bien sûr. C'est pour ça que je revenais sur les normes, parce qu'en fait, il y a une manière d'écrire sur LinkedIn qu'on n'écrirait pas sur Facebook, qu'on n'écrirait pas sur Twitter, qu'on n'écrirait pas sur tout autre réseau social.
Et en fait, c'est justement ça, c'est qu'il y a ces normes, et au final, LinkedIn, il est bien spécifique. Si maintenant, je te montrais, par exemple, une publication LinkedIn, tu saurais que c'est LinkedIn, forcément, en fait.
Et c'est aussi pour ça que je disais, en termes d'effet sur la santé mentale, c'est pour ça que je m'intéresse aux différences entre ces plateformes, parce que c'est très difficile de dire que toutes les plateformes vont avoir le même effet.
Parce qu'en fait, les messages ne sont pas les mêmes, ils ne sont pas formulés de la même manière, on n'y voit pas les mêmes personnes, on n'a pas les mêmes algorithmes, on n'a pas la même architecture, pas la même manière de se connecter aux autres.
Mh. Si je devais résumer un peu le stéréotype, le cliché que j'ai en tête pour LinkedIn,
c'est effectivement des posts où tout le monde fait des trois sauts de ligne entre chaque phrase, exprime qu'il faut se lever à cinq heures du matin pour prendre une douche froide, qu'il faut traiter son fils comme un employé.
En fait, il y a un compte Twitter que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Real Humans of LinkedIn, avec pas mal de posts comme ça qui sont repris.
Bon alors évidemment, tout le monde n'est pas comme ça, mais c'est quand même un peu le truc typique qu'on peut trouver sur LinkedIn, je trouve.
Est-ce que c'est complètement hors sol, ce que je dis, ou bien est-ce qu'il y a un peu de vrai là-dedans,
derrière ce cliché ?
J'ai pas lu d'études sur exactement les normes. Par exemple, j'ai travaillé sur Twitter, sur les normes Twitter.
Donc je pourrais dire : j'ai pas travaillé sur les normes LinkedIn, donc je voudrais pas m'avancer en disant que LinkedIn, c'est typiquement ce type de, ce genre de contenu.
Maintenant, oui, il y a clairement un type de format. Pour tester, par exemple, si on va sur ChatGPT et qu'on prend une publication Twitter et qu'on demande de la transformer en publication LinkedIn, on peut voir que ChatGPT le fait.
Donc il y a déjà, même au niveau de l'intelligence artificielle—
Il rajoute les sauts de ligne entre chaque phrase ?
Oui. Il rajoute aussi les smileys, parce qu'il y a des smileys, voilà, qui sont différents, évidemment, selon chaque plateforme. Donc c'est vrai.
Oui. Je pense que je l'ai déjà dit par le passé. Moi, j'ai supprimé mon compte LinkedIn tellement, tellement ça me fait vomir.
Mais donc OK, on a parlé d'Instagram puis de LinkedIn. LinkedIn, en termes de bien-être, est-ce qu'on observe un impact négatif ou bien c'est globalement assez neutre ?
J'ai jamais lu aucune recherche sur LinkedIn et le bien-être. Parce que justement, c'est un réseau professionnel. Donc la plupart du temps, les recherches sur LinkedIn, elles sont plus dans le cadre professionnel, en fait, tout simplement.
Et est-ce que ça nous permet d'avoir du réseautage ? Est-ce qu'on va plus postuler sur LinkedIn ou des choses comme ça ?
Le contenu, les photos, tout le monde est tout propre sur sa photo de profil. C'est très, oui... C'est, y a un côté performatif.
Bien sûr. Parce que c'est un réseau professionnel. On performe le soi professionnel, en fait, dans ce qu'on va mettre, dans les recommandations qu'on va mettre aux autres, dans ce qu'on va montrer, dans ce qu'on va publier.
Mais ce qui est vraiment difficile, c'est la pression de devoir le faire. C'est-à-dire que si on veut, dans le monde professionnel, à un moment donné,
avoir de la visibilité, LinkedIn peut devenir incontournable et c'est là où peut-être ça devient difficile.
Passons maintenant alors sur TikTok, le nouveau player depuis— Ça a été fait quand ? Quelle année ?
2016, mais un peu plus tard en France. Je pense que ça a vraiment explosé en France à partir de la pandémie 2020. C'est-à-dire que c'était déjà là, mais le nombre d'inscrits a explosé pendant la pandémie.
Je me souviens qu'effectivement, peut-être en 2019, quand je regardais, il y avait encore— Parce que donc avant, ça s'appelait Musical.ly, il me semble, ouais.
Et il me semble que les premières années où j'essayais l'application, il y avait quand même beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de très très jeunes utilisateurs, des préados que je voyais danser, etc.
Et puis, au fur et à mesure, le temps passant, bon, déjà, évidemment, il a un peu ciblé son algorithme sur ce qui m'intéresse, mais j'ai l'impression que le public s'est élargi.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord. Je pense que TikTok a souffert, si je peux utiliser ce terme, de stéréotypes aussi vis-à-vis de la plateforme.
Et je pense qu'encore maintenant, pour des personnes qui n'utilisent pas TikTok, il y a une vision aussi où c'est forcément des ados qui vont danser devant nous en bikini.
J'en sais rien, mais c'est pas du tout le contenu que j'ai sur TikTok. J'ai des vidéos de chiens, principalement.
Ce qui est très drôle, c'est quand t'entends des vieux politiciens qui disent : « Moi, quand j'ouvre TikTok, je ne vois que des femmes jeunes, prépubères qui dansent », etc.
Tu fais : « Mais... C'est... »
C'est inquiétant.
Tu dois passer beaucoup de temps à les regarder, ces vidéos. Mais donc, ouais, le contenu, effectivement, varie très fort en fonction de l'utilisateur, donc c'est très dur de dire—
Exactement.
Objectivement.
J'ai pas fait l'étude, mais j'avais en tête de tester parce que je l'avais fait, mais totalement pour le plaisir.
Donc c'était pas du tout scientifique, mais de tester si on télécharge l'application et qu'on est un homme ou une femme.
Déjà, est-ce que le contenu est déjà orienté dès le début ? Et c'est vrai que quand on est un homme, c'est pas pour défendre les politiciens, mais quand on est un homme, c'est vrai que
les premières images étaient souvent ce type d'images et ce qui était moins le cas, par exemple, pour les femmes, ça mérite d'être testé.
Mais vu qu'on n'a pas accès aux algorithmes, je peux pas savoir. Est-ce que dans l'algorithme, par exemple, c'est quelque chose qui rentre en compte par rapport au genre de l'utilisateur ?
Peut-être. Mais vu qu'on n'a pas accès à ces algorithmes, en tant que chercheur, on peut juste deviner ou prétendre et voilà.
En tout cas, pour TikTok, je pense qu'il a effectivement souffert de stéréotypes dont il souffre toujours, hein.
C'est aussi un réseau social qui est chinois, donc il souffre aussi de ça.
Et peut-être légitimement.
Peut-être légitimement, exactement.
De vraies questions qui se posent là-dessus. Je vais juste représenter un petit peu vite fait la façon dont ça fonctionne.
Donc concrètement, on a un flux avec des vidéos format plutôt court, même si maintenant, ça peut être un peu plus long. Et concrètement, on swipe avec son doigt de haut en bas pour faire défiler les vidéos.
Il y a assez peu d'interface autour de la vidéo, ça occupe tout l'écran du smartphone. Et vraiment, c'est comme un tuyau d'arrosage en termes de données pour l'algorithme, puisqu'on regarde la vidéo.
Si on reste longtemps dessus ou si on la zappe vite, c'est déjà une information. Si on la like, c'est une autre information.
Si on la partage, c'est une autre information. Si on choisit de s'abonner au créateur de contenu, c'est encore une information.
Et donc comme c'est des formats courts, vraiment, l'utilisateur donne énormément de data, mais très très vite et constamment sur le contenu qui lui plaît.
Et donc oui, il a très vite capté quels sont les
les types de musique qui me plaisent, les types de— les films que j'aime bien, les jeux vidéo qui m'ont beaucoup plu, les sujets politiques qui sont importants pour moi, dans quel pays j'habite.
Enfin bref, et donc vraiment, on ouvre TikTok, enfin j'ouvre TikTok et je tombe très vite sur quelque chose de très très très...
Je sais pas si on peut dire que c'est echo chamber, mais c'est du sur mesure, c'est taillé sur mesure et c'est très impressionnant, et donc très chronophage.
Enfin, c'est très addictif, disons. Est-ce que c'est juste de dire que TikTok est plus addictif que d'autres réseaux sur base de la,
le, oui, le tailor-made, le sur mesure qu'il est capable de faire grâce à son algorithme ?
Alors en recherche sur les réseaux sociaux, on a du mal à utiliser le terme d'addiction, on pourra peut-être y revenir après.
D'accord.
Cela dit, on a peu de preuves de nouveau parce que
ça a explosé en 2020 et la recherche prend du temps. Donc même s'il y a quelques recherches qui sont sorties, je pourrais pas prétendre de dire que voilà, c'est— il faut quand même avoir plusieurs recherches en
en sciences pour affirmer quelque chose et encore, même là.
Mais bon, TikTok est très particulier. Alors déjà, il y a le fait que ce soit des vidéos parce que
on sait que les vidéos ont un effet différent, par exemple, que les images ou que le texte, d'un point de vue psychologique, tout simplement parce qu'elles sont beaucoup plus engageantes,
beaucoup plus interactives tout simplement.
Donc déjà, on sait qu'il y a cet aspect-là. Le deuxième aspect, c'est que les vidéos sur TikTok, même si ça a été rallongé de manière générale, sont courtes.
C'est pas comme sur YouTube où on va voir des vidéos d'une heure ou de cinquante minutes, ce qui fait qu'on peut très très vite consommer du contenu court qui est interactif.
Ce qui fait que pour l'instant, on a des suppositions que TikTok pourrait avoir des effets très différents des autres réseaux sociaux, que c'est un réseau social à part qui pourrait avoir des effets très différents.
Mais pour l'instant, on a rien en fait pour l'étayer.
Mh. Ok, je comprends que ça soit compliqué à répondre à ce stade. Une autre spécificité de TikTok, c'est les fameux filtres.
Donc il y a des filtres,
encore une fois, j'explique pour les gens qui connaissent pas du tout, mais il y a des filtres où on va voir quel personnage de Disney êtes-vous et ça va défiler par-dessus la tête de la personne et une petite blague là-dessus.
Enfin, des filtres qui se veulent, enfin, ça s'appelle des filtres, mais en vrai, c'est un overlay, quelque chose qui va superposer sur la vidéo et donc qui va avoir des buts humoristiques.
Et puis il y a les filtres qui posent plus question, le fameux filtre glamour, les fameuses fonctions pour se blanchir les dents, pour avoir une peau plus unie.
Il me semble, oui, je connais une—
je suis une utilisatrice belge qui poste du contenu, qui s'appelle Alesliz, et
elle est partie en Corée pendant un an, je crois, l'an dernier, et elle montrait que dès le moment où elle posait les pieds en Corée, elle avait, entre guillemets, le TikTok coréen
où par défaut, il y avait beaucoup beaucoup plus de filtres qui s'activaient sur son visage.
Et donc bon voilà, tout ça pose la question encore une fois, la question de la comparaison avec autrui.
Tu disais comparaison—
Ascendante.
Ascendante, c'est ça, oui, oui.
Et oui, effectivement. Donc il y a cet aspect de filtre sur TikTok, mais de nouveau, ça a pas encore été étudié.
C'est vraiment, je suis désolée.
Je suis sûr, hein, de poser des questions—
Non, pas du tout, parce que c'est intéressant, parce que c'est d'actualité et qu'on fait notre maximum, mais qu'effectivement, la recherche prend du temps.
On a quand même quelques phénomènes qui ont été étudiés sur TikTok. On a notamment le phénomène de tics TikTok. Donc je sais pas si t'en as entendu parler, mais c'est le fait qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'adolescentes qui ont développé des tics.
Il y a quelques travaux qui commencent à émerger sur la question de : est-ce que parce qu'on parle de santé mentale sur TikTok, ce qui arrive souvent, est-ce que ça peut influencer les personnes à s'autodiagnostiquer ou à développer des troubles ?
Quand tu dis des tics, tu...
Des tics de langage. Donc c'est, y a différents types de tics, effectivement.
Est-ce que c'est le diagnostic des tics qui apparaît ou est-ce que c'est juste le tic en lui-même qui n'était pas là avant et qui se fait remarquer après ?
C'est des tics qui sont pas là et qui apparaissent. Alors, c'est une question que les scientifiques se posent.
Alors après, moi, je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec les recherches parce que ce que veulent montrer ces recherches-là, c'est souvent que TikTok a tendance aussi peut avoir un effet
de glamouriser d'une certaine manière la maladie mentale et que ça peut entraîner des personnes à, du coup, simplement,
par recherche d'attention ou quelque chose comme ça.
Alors moi, mon avis, c'est que c'est beaucoup plus complexe. Ça peut arriver, pourquoi pas, mais il y a aussi le fait que, et on n'en a pas parlé, on n'a pas parlé beaucoup des effets positifs des réseaux sociaux,
mais j'ai quand même envie de souligner ça.
Il y a aussi cet aspect qu'il y a des personnes qui se rendent pas compte qu'ils vivent quelque chose et qui, grâce à TikTok, s'en rendent compte.
Il y a aussi la prise d'information. Et donc, en fait, pour TikTok, on a quand même assez peu d'effets, mais on avait ce phénomène où ils avaient l'impression qu'il y avait une sous-culture de la maladie mentale sur TikTok, aussi avec l'autisme,
où il y a vraiment beaucoup de débats sur est-ce que TikTok peut
amener les gens à s'autodiagnostiquer autistes.
Et c'est compliqué, c'est complexe. Et c'est pour ça qu'au début, je voulais souligner que les réseaux sociaux, c'est aussi des fois juste un contexte social.
Est-ce que c'est vraiment TikTok ou est-ce que c'est TikTok qui est une source d'information, qui est une sour— enfin, est-ce que quelqu'un qui aurait vu une émission de télévision ou qui aurait discuté avec des gens dans son entourage,
on n'arriverait pas au même.
C'est très très compliqué de faire la part des choses.
Mh. C'est des questions intéressantes. En effet, je suis comme toi, je suis très sceptique par rapport à l'idée de penser que c'est un effet de mode ou que les gens,
je reste surpris par cette idée que les gens développent des tics parce qu'ils passent du temps sur TikTok, ça me—
Et c'est une vraie idée.
Curieux. Mais c'est une idée ou bien c'est—
C'est des recherches, je les ai lues, mais c'est tout nouveau hein, donc c'est aux balbutiements.
Mais ce qui a été fait, c'est par exemple regarder la prévalence des tics en temps normal et regarder la prévalence des tics après l'explosion de TikTok dans des portions de personnes qui ont utilisé TikTok et de montrer effectivement qu'il y en a plus.
Et du coup ce qu'ils ont fait aussi, c'est regarder les personnes qui, donc il y a des personnes qui font des vidéos sur TikTok en ayant des tics tout simplement.
Et en fait, ils ont analysé les types de tics qu'ils avaient. Parce qu'en fait, il faut savoir que y a pas, par exemple, le syndrome de la Tourette qu'on entend souvent parler, c'est très spécifique.
Y a pas beaucoup de gens qui l'ont, mais à côté, il y a des tics qui peuvent être très courants en fait. Y a des personnes qui ont des tics et on le remarque pas tant que ça en fait.
Ça peut être— je suis pas une experte des tics, donc je voudrais pas non plus trop m'avancer, mais y a des tics qui sont beaucoup plus courants.
Et en fait, ils ont simplement regardé sur les vidéos le type de tics qui apparaissait. Et ils ont remarqué que c'était souvent des tics qui sont très très très très rares alors que la plupart des gens qui ont des tics ont des tics qui sont plutôt doux.
Et en fait, ils ont essayé de comparer ça ou par exemple de voir si c'était des tics du langage ou des tics plutôt physiques.
Et donc en fait, c'est grâce à ça qu'ils ont déterminé qu'effectivement, on a l'impression que les tics, en tout cas les gens qui parlent sur TikTok et qui ont des tics,
ne correspondent pas à ce qu'on devrait attendre si on se base sur les taux de prévalence traditionnels.
Voilà. Donc c'est une méthodologie qui est pourquoi pas intéressante. Après moi en science, j'encourage toujours à mixer en fait les approches qu'on utilise et y a plein d'autres méthodes pour confirmer ou non confirmer ce type d'analyse.
Cela dit, c'est intéressant et ça montre que TikTok questionne énormément, peut-être beaucoup plus que les autres réseaux sociaux.
Ce que moi, j'ai déjà pu observer, c'est des personnes qui effectivement parlent des questions de neurodiversité. Par exemple, je vois une personne qui
utilisait un filtre avec, je sais plus, un personnage qui danse ou je sais pas quoi.
Et elle fait une blague sur le fait qu'elle a un TDAH. Et elle montre, ben voilà, ce personnage de ce filtre, c'est comme moi quand je travaille, quand je suis distrait à cause de mon TDAH.
Et la remarque que je me suis faite en voyant ça, c'est qu'il y a une réappropriation des discours autour des questions de neurodiversité pour vraiment traiter ça comme un sujet léger, drôle, plutôt que
laisser ces discours, par exemple, aux soignants, aux psychologues, comme un sujet plutôt grave et plutôt sérieux et un truc à soigner, etc.
Et il y a une, ouais, une démocratisation, une— et je trouvais ça assez bien en fait, cette idée de donner la parole, donner, oui, donner la parole, vulgariser, normaliser toutes ces choses-là.
Ça, je trouve ça plutôt bien, ouais.
C'est pour ça que je dis que c'est difficile de faire la part des choses quand on est chercheur, parce qu'en fait, il y a un point de vue sociétal et tout le monde a un point de vue sur les réseaux sociaux.
Si là je m'arrêtais et je demande à quelqu'un : « Est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bon ou mauvais ? Est-ce que ça a un mauvais impact sur vous ?
» J'aurais énormément de réponses, toutes différentes en fonction de ce que les gens ont vécu, de leur expérience, de leur âge.
Et c'est ça qui est très très compliqué en fait.
Ok. Et donc on a parlé de TikTok, LinkedIn, Instagram. Donc les deux principaux sont Twitter et Facebook, même si Twitter, en fait, c'est une petite minorité de gens qui sont dessus.
Ça va être des politiciens, des journalistes, des gens très très instruits, des gens dans la sphère académique, etc.
Mais qui est quand même très très couvert dans les médias, assez central. On va afficher dans les, sur les chaînes d'info, on va afficher les tweets, etc.
Enfin, c'est une institution assez centrale, mais avec finalement assez peu d'utilisateurs et une politique qui pose question depuis quelques mois.
Donc parlons du, la question du bien-être, la question aussi du cyberharcèlement sur Twitter. Qu'est-ce qui est spécifique sur Twitter en termes de, vis-à-vis de ces questions-là ?
Alors déjà, je suis tout à fait d'accord. Beaucoup moins d'utilisateurs sur Twitter et des utilisateurs qui sont de manière générale plus instruits, un petit peu plus des hommes.
On sait pourquoi hein.
Alors le fait est qu'en fait, Twitter, à la base, c'était vraiment, comme tu disais, pour les journalistes. Ce qui fait que c'est normal que finalement à la télévision, ils citent des tweets parce qu'ils sont dessus en fait.
Enfin, ça me semble une certaine logique. Le fait est que du coup, ça a amené certaines, on parlait de normes, mais il y en a aussi sur Twitter, c'est ce que je disais.
Et en fait, vu que c'était le monde journalistique, on a tendance dans le monde journalistique à présenter les informations de manière négative parce que ça attire plus en fait.
C'est-à-dire qu'un titre de journal qui est négatif va plus attirer qu'un titre qui est positif et les informations négatives sont plus souvent le plus partagées par rapport aux informations positives.
Et souvent, les normes sur Twitter, c'est qu'il faut que ce soit négatif, brut, naturel. Alors que quand on va comparer par exemple Instagram, on va nous dire qu'il faut que ce soit positif, idéalisé.
Et donc en fait, quand on est sur Twitter, on a vraiment ces normes-là de négativité qui peuvent amener plus facilement à des comportements de trolls ou des cyberharcèlements.
Parce que forcément, on est dans un environnement qui est de facto négatif et où les gens se sentent, en tout cas, ils sont dans la norme quand ils le font.
C'est-à-dire que quand on est négatif sur Twitter, on est en fait dans la norme. Et tout le monde s'attend à ce que ce soit comme ça sur Twitter.
Je veux dire, si on demande même à quelqu'un qui n'a pas Twitter qu'est-ce qu'il en pense, il va dire : « C'est forcément des débats longs où les personnes vont vouloir affirmer leur opinion sans vouloir écouter l'opinion de l'autre.
» Tout ce qui est le filter bubble, c'est souvent Twitter qu'on a en tête. Mais ce qui est assez intéressant, c'est que Twitter est aussi un des réseaux sociaux les plus étudiés dans la communauté scientifique.
Et une des raisons pour ça, c'est qu'avant ces derniers mois, même si c'est toujours le cas pour l'instant, les chercheurs pouvaient accéder aux tweets.
Oui.
C'est toujours le cas pour l'instant, mais c'est—
Presque fini quoi.
Voilà, c'est presque fini.
C'est sur le point de finir, ouais.
Et ça, ça a fait que Twitter, du coup, les chercheurs, comme je disais, c'est difficile pour nous, chercheurs, d'aborder ces questions de
des effets des réseaux sociaux. Et pouvoir tout simplement recueillir toutes les publications de tous les utilisateurs, ça offre des possibilités en termes d'analyse et de recherche énormes.
Ce qui fait que, du coup, je dirais, pour une question de ressources, eh ben Twitter reste un des réseaux sociaux les plus étudiés, avec Facebook.
Et Facebook, c'est parce que c'était le premier, évidemment.
OK. Et en ce qui concerne la question du cyberharcèlement, moi, je suis un peu biaisé puisque c'est fort là-dessus que se concentre le documentaire Sale Pute.
Je sais pas si t'as eu l'occasion de le voir ?
Non, je crois pas, non.
C'est un documentaire qui parle de cyberharcèlement, qui a fait le tour en Belgique et en France, mais donc qui exprimait clairement l'idée que sur,
que sur Twitter, l'expérience des femmes était bien, bien, bien pire que sur les autres réseaux sociaux, que le cyberharcèlement était vraiment très très peu modéré, vraiment omniprésent.
Est-ce que tes travaux vont dans le même sens ?
Alors, j'ai pas étudié directement la question du cyberharcèlement sur Twitter, mais ce qui est une vérité, c'est que, parce qu'on a des normes beaucoup plus négatives, les gens ont tendance, sur Twitter...
Enfin, je veux dire, ça arrive sur Instagram, mais quelqu'un qui dit : « T'es nul », on va beaucoup plus facilement le faire sur Twitter que sur Instagram.
Ce qui fait qu'effectivement, le vécu souvent des personnes est très très différent si on poste. Et beaucoup de gens disent qu'ils ne veulent pas utiliser Twitter ou qu'ils ne veulent pas publier sur Twitter parce que justement, ils ont peur.
Ils anticipent ces répercussions et c'est pas forcément quelque chose qu'on retrouve sur les autres réseaux sociaux.
Donc, je sais pas, j'ai pas exactement travaillé sur la question du cyberharcèlement, mais je sais qu'effectivement, les utilisateurs se bloquent eux-mêmes parce que justement, ils sont effrayés par ces questions-là.
Et par exemple, sur tout ce qui est le mouvement MeToo, y a par exemple des analyses qui s'intéressaient à ce que les victimes ou les survivantes, mais en tout cas, écrivaient dans leurs publications.
Et on voit que c'est écrit de manière très différente sur Instagram, par exemple, ou sur Twitter. Parce que souvent sur Twitter, on va appeler à la mobilisation.
On est sur des choses beaucoup plus factuelles, alors que sur Instagram, on va pouvoir donner plus d'informations sur ce qui s'est réellement passé, chose qu'on ferait pas forcément sur Twitter.
Après, y a aussi le fait effectivement que sur Twitter, on a une limite de caractères, hein. C'est pour ça que je disais c'est très compliqué, parce qu'il y a beaucoup de facteurs qui font qu'on a des différences entre les plateformes.
Ouais, ouais. Limite de caractères qui d'ailleurs a sauté si on décide de payer les huit dollars par mois.
Oui.
Pour les rares personnes qui trouvent que c'est une bonne idée. Et donc, plutôt une ambiance négative.
De manière générale, on s'attend à avoir du contenu négatif. Ça me surprend un petit peu puisque
je trouve que c'est pas rare de voir des gens qui font des blagues ou plutôt des gens qui sont sur un t-- moi, j'aurais dit un ton vraiment partage de l'information, commentaire sur l'information, peut-être des blagues.
Bon après, évidemment, l'expérience de chaque réseau va dépendre de chaque personne. Ce que moi, je vois,
je suis certainement pas en train de dire que c'est représentatif de l'expérience générale, mais ça va être, voilà, un ton plutôt relais de l'information, expression d'opinion, mais sur un ton, voilà,
pas spécialement toxique.
sauf évidemment si,
Concrètement, mon expérience, c'est que si j'interview une personnalité, voilà, vaguement féministe ou très féministe ou controversée,
ou très à gauche ou quelque chose comme ça, là, je peux facilement me retrouver avec,
avec plein d'interactions très très toxiques, et beaucoup plus que sur les autres réseaux sociaux.
Et comment est-ce qu'on explique ça, se laisser faire, cette absence de blocage, de barrière, de protection ?
Alors déjà, pour répondre, quand je disais négatif, c'est toujours en comparaison avec les autres réseaux sociaux.
Bien sûr, ouais.
Et c'est-à-dire que c'est pas forcément négatif comme on l'entendrait, mais par rapport à Instagram, quand on lit des publications Twitter, on n'est pas dans le même ordre, même si ça peut arriver, bien sûr.
Pas dans le good mood.
Exactement.
Bonne ambiance.
Il y a aussi le fait que c'est négatif et souvent, en tout cas, réel. C'est-à-dire qu'on a l'impression que les autres réseaux sociaux sont plutôt idéalisés, alors que sur Twitter, on dit des choses réelles.
Il y a aussi beaucoup de memes, il y a beaucoup aussi d'amusement, hein, sur Twitter. Exactement. Mais on reste sur critiquer la réalité.
Il y a un aspect, en fait, beaucoup plus de critique que de contemplement qu'on pourrait avoir sur les autres réseaux sociaux.
Donc c'était plus dans cet ordre d'idée-là que j'y pensais. Après, de ce que j'ai lu, on n'a pas forcément d'explications sur pourquoi sur Twitter, il y aurait plus de cyberharcèlement qu'ailleurs.
Pour moi, ça repose beaucoup sur le fait que les gens sont habitués, en fait. Et il y a aussi parfois plus d'anonymat sur Twitter qu'il n'y en a sur d'autres plateformes.
Parce que Facebook, on va ajouter ses amis, donc forcément, ben on a notre photo de profil. On peut être anonyme sur chaque réseau social, hein, mais je veux dire...
Ben sur Facebook, c'est compliqué parce que y avait la question des drag queens ou des questions comme ça où on...
Ben par exemple, je connais une personne qui a changé de genre, changé de prénom, et au moment où la personne a voulu changer le nom qu'elle affichait sur,
sur Facebook, on lui a demandé une preuve d'identité, une carte d'identité, etc.
Donc quand même, l'anonymat sur Facebook ou le fait d'employer un nom qui n'est pas le sien, c'est plus trop possible à ce stade.
Effectivement. Et sur Instagram, on peut toujours, mais souvent, les gens ont juste pas l'habitude. C'est-à-dire que sur Instagram, on peut mettre un pseudo, y a pas tout le monde qui met son nom, mais souvent, on va mettre des photos de soi.
Donc à un moment donné, l'anonymat va forcément sauter à un moment donné. C'est moins le cas sur Twitter, parce qu'en fait, sur Twitter, souvent, ça va être des avatars pour les photos.
Les noms, souvent, c'est pas forcément le cas. Alors, il y a beaucoup de gens qui s'identifient sur Twitter, hein, qui ont pas peur non plus d'harceler en ayant leur nom, mais c'est un des phénomènes aussi qui peut intervenir.
C'est effectivement une critique qu'on entendait pendant très longtemps, c'était que tous ces comportements étaient en grande partie liés à la capacité des gens de se cacher derrière un pseudo ou d'être anonyme. Effectivement,
depuis, je dirais, une petite dizaine d'années, on observe sans problème des, même des personnalités publiques, même des journalistes qui ne cachent pas du tout leur nom, qui le font vraiment à visage découvert, donc
Alors, il y a des recherches qui montrent aussi que les gens se sentent anonymes des fois, même s'ils ne le sont pas.
OK. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire se sentir anonyme ?
C'est-à-dire qu'on leur demande : « Est-ce que vous pensez être retrouvable ou anonyme, par exemple, sur les réseaux sociaux ?
» Et des gens répondent oui.
Ils se sentent-- ils ont un sentiment d'immunité, quoi.
Exactement, qui n'est pas le cas aussi. Et on retrouve ça aussi beaucoup pour tout ce qui est confidentialité, mais aussi le fait que les images et ce qu'ils disent va rester pendant des années.
Et les précédents légaux ne leur donnent pas tort puisque, bon, là, je vais parler de la Belgique en particulier que tu connais peut-être un peu moins, mais effectivement, concrètement, le harcèlement en Belgique naît
pratiquement, sauf de rares exceptions comme celui de Myriam Leroy ou Florence Hainaut qui arrivent à poursuivre en justice le harceleur.
De manière générale, effectivement, ce sentiment d'immunité est assez légitime. On n'est pas-
Après, du côté de la loi, effectivement, les réseaux sociaux, c'est très très très compliqué à réguler,
pour toutes les raisons qui fait qu'il y a des gens du monde entier, que les plateformes ne sont pas forcément, alors, elles le sont de plus en plus, mais elles ne sont pas forcément volontaires.
En fait, ça dépend des pays. Et le problème, c'est que, par exemple, on a des lois différentes entre chaque pays. Les plateformes viennent de pays différents.
On n'a pas de plateforme européenne, on a Mastodon, mais je sais pas si ça a assez explosé pour dire que... Mais c'est très compliqué.
Et il y a des recherches qui sont faites justement sur ces lois. Alors bon, pas tout à fait sur la question de cyberharcèlement, mais par exemple sur mettre sur Instagram l'obligation de dire quand c'est du contenu qui est-
Retouché ?
Qui est sponsorisé.
Ah oui.
Et ça, par exemple, en Allemagne, ils sont beaucoup plus stricts qu'on ne l'est en France, et beaucoup moins qu'ils le sont, par exemple, au Brésil.
Et donc forcément, en Allemagne, ils sont obligés, les influenceurs, de le faire, de mettre sur les réseaux sociaux quand c'est sponsorisé ou pas.
Et donc, il y a des recherches qui commencent à voir si ces lois ont des effets. Globalement, oui, mais c'est très très compliqué en termes de régulation, et ça demande un vrai travail,
une vraie coopération en fait, parce qu'il faut des preuves pour justifier certaines lois.
Il faut que les lois soient appuyées aussi par les plateformes. Il faut que les utilisateurs veuillent respecter les lois et pas les contourner.
Et ça, c'est très complexe.
Donc, on a fait un petit peu le tour des différentes plateformes au niveau de la question du bien-être. On va
parler des autres sujets sur lesquels tu as travaillé, notamment la question de prise de parole dans le cas d'agressions sexuelles, la question de, voilà, de sentiment
politique, sentiment d'européanité.
C'est le bon mot ?
On peut dire identité européenne, mais oui.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Euro-identité.
Voilà. Merci. Euro-identité, c'est, ouais, c'est plus chouette. Mais avant de passer sur tout ça, est-ce que tu peux rajouter quelque chose vis-à-vis de la question du bien-être sur les plateformes ?
Je dirais qu'on n'a vraiment pas abordé à quel point les réseaux sociaux, ça peut être aussi bénéfique.
Oui.
C'est aussi pour moi une des raisons aussi pour lesquelles, quand on fait nos recherches, on n'a pas un effet négatif.
On a un tout petit effet parce qu'en fait, il est mangé, si je pourrais dire, par tous les effets différents que ça peut avoir pour chaque individu différent.
Parce que les réseaux sociaux, c'est aussi, donc c'est finalement un contenu, par exemple, on parlait de l'algorithme.
Il va nous amener à avoir du contenu qui va dans le sens de nos opinions, mais c'est pas toujours négatif. C'est-à-dire que, comme je disais, en tant qu'individu, des fois, on a besoin aussi d'avoir des choses qui nous confortent.
Et par exemple, des personnes qui se posent des questions à l'adolescence.
Donc souvent, je prends l'exemple de l'orientation sexuelle, mais c'est vraiment, les réseaux sociaux, ça
peut leur permettre déjà de rencontrer des gens qui vivent la même chose qu'eux, auxquels ils peuvent s'identifier pour se projeter justement dans l'avenir.
Et c'est quelque chose qui était des fois pas possible avant les réseaux sociaux. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui se sentaient juste démunis.
C'est aussi une grosse source d'information. On oublie que les informations sont une grosse source d'information. Comme je disais, quand on y va, on n'y va pas simplement pour se comparer aux autres ou pour se montrer qu'on est beau.
On va aussi sur les réseaux sociaux parce qu'on veut parler à nos proches, des personnes qui sont seules, qui sont loin de leurs proches.
On l'a vu aussi pendant la pandémie de COVID. Sans les réseaux sociaux, beaucoup de gens se seraient sentis très isolés.
Donc, je trouve que des fois, on passe sous silence à quel point les réseaux sociaux ont aussi une place considérable dans notre vie.
On parlait de LinkedIn. Beaucoup de gens ont eu des opportunités professionnelles, mais aussi juste, des fois, intellectuelles, si je peux dire comme ça, mais plus d'échanges qu'ils n'auraient jamais eus sans.
C'est-à-dire que les réseaux sociaux, on va dire qu'il y a des points négatifs, mais des points aussi très positifs. Et ce qui est compliqué, c'est que quelque chose qui peut être vu comme négatif peut être vu comme positif.
Par exemple, l'anonymat, c'est quelque chose qui peut amener-- alors, je suis pas revenue dessus, mais est-ce que ça amène vraiment à des comportements négatifs ?
C'est vraiment débattu dans la littérature. Et non, pas forcément. L'anonymat ne va pas rendre-- c'est pas parce qu'on est anonyme qu'on va devenir d'un coup un tueur en série. C'est faux.
Non.
Mais l'anonymat peut avoir des effets négatifs. On peut imaginer, par exemple, sur des questions de stalking ou des choses comme ça ou de cyberharcèlement, ça peut avoir aussi des effets très positifs.
Des personnes qui n'osent pas parler de certains événements de leur vie, mais qui, du coup, vont réussir à en parler sous couvert d'anonymat, quelque chose qu'ils auraient jamais pu faire.
Et ça, ça peut les aider à se sentir mieux. Donc, c'est là que c'est très complexe, c'est que c'est des plateformes, c'est des outils et que ces outils peuvent avoir des effets aussi bien négatifs que positifs.
Et c'est là aussi où c'est difficile à réguler au niveau des États, de la loi et des plateformes, parce que des choses qui peuvent être des fois prises comme de la liberté d'expression peuvent
se transformer en discours haineux.
Et la frontière, des fois, est tellement fine, ou parfois, elle ne l'est pas du tout, mais des fois, elle l'est. Et là, c'est compliqué de savoir exactement ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on devrait faire dans ce cas-là.
Donc c'est super parce que ça rejoint donc la toute première question que je t'ai posée en disant : Est-ce que c'est bien ?
Est-ce que c'est mal ? Mais donc effectivement, beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de nuances. Il y a des aspects positifs, des aspects négatifs et surtout, il reste encore beaucoup de questions.
Mais ça, c'est toujours comme ça dans la recherche.
Alors, c'est toujours comme ça dans la recherche. Et puis les réseaux sociaux, c'est quand même quelque chose de très très particulier parce que c'est mouvant en fait, tout le temps.
C'est-à-dire qu'on parlait par exemple de WhatsApp qui a ajouté des stories. Mais le fait est que les stories, à la base, c'était sur Snapchat et que maintenant, c'est sur Facebook, c'est sur Instagram, c'est partout en fait.
Et la vérité, c'est qu'en fait, ce sont des plateformes qui évoluent avec leurs utilisateurs. Twitter aussi a été pendant longtemps façonné par les utilisateurs,
ce qui fait que les gens l'aimaient beaucoup et ce qui fait que d'autres l'aimaient pas du tout parce qu'ils avaient l'impression que c'était une plateforme qui était-
Stable ou...
Pas forcément stable, mais qui était pour un groupe de personnes et que c'était très difficile d'y rentrer en fait.
Ce qui est vrai, d'une certaine manière.
Et donc, en fait, la vraie complexité, c'est que ces plateformes sont mouvantes et j'en ai pas parlé non plus, mais de manière générale, dès qu'il y a un nouvel outil de communication qui arrivait dans notre univers, si je peux dire ça comme ça, on s'en est méfié.
C'est-à-dire que quand on a eu l'imprimerie, on s'est méfié de l'imprimerie. Quand on a eu les journaux, on s'est méfié des journaux.
Quand on a eu la télévision, on s'est méfié de la télévision. C'est-à-dire que c'est humain d'avoir peur que ces nouvelles technologies prennent une place considérable.
Et en ce moment, on se méfie de l'intelligence artificielle.
Mmm-hmm.
La spécificité des réseaux sociaux par rapport à ces autres plateformes, c'est le fait que pour ces plateformes-là, on disait souvent que les effets étaient uniformes parce qu'on avait un contenu,
on considérait que l'audience était juste la même et que du coup, les effets étaient similaires pour tout le monde.
Ce qui n'était pas tout à fait vrai non plus. Mais du coup, la différence avec les réseaux sociaux, c'est que là, on peut plus parler de ça parce que c'est personnalisé par l'algorithme, parce que d'une certaine manière, on peut,
on peut nous-même personnaliser cette plateforme.
C'est nous qui allions-- on va être beaucoup plus actif. C'est-à-dire quand je regarde la télévision, je suis pas spécialement active.
Quand je suis sur les réseaux sociaux, je peux l'être.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc c'est là aussi où ça complexifie beaucoup, on va dire, cet outil par rapport aux autres outils qu'on a eus dans le passé pour communiquer.
Parce que les journaux, la télévision, ce sont aussi des moyens de communiquer les uns avec les autres.
Oui, donc beaucoup de nuances. Et on associe souvent, en particulier Facebook, à par exemple, la montée du fascisme, la campagne de Donald Trump en 2016, etc.
Et donc, mais comme tu dis, en même temps, il y a une parole qui est donnée à peut-être des minorités qui peuvent trouver d'autres voies qui peuvent les aider en termes de santé mentale.
Donc il y a beaucoup de complexité. Donc, comme tu dis, il y a à la fois du positif et du négatif.
Ma position, c'est qu'il y a en tout cas des questions à se poser vis-à-vis de la propriété, l'appartenance de ces plateformes à des multimilliardaires comme Elon Musk ou comme Zuckerberg, qui
ont peut-être des intérêts, voilà, et qui peuvent
faire des choix stratégiques qui vont être pour le profit, notamment, voilà, favoriser via leurs algorithmes des contenus.
Alors, on l'a vu, hein, depuis qu'Elon Musk a changé quelques politiques sur Twitter, beaucoup plus de contenus haineux, agressifs.
On dirait que Twitter était un environnement relativement négatif, mais là, c'est encore pire depuis quelques mois.
C'est vraiment fascinant parce que c'est à la fois un terrain de jeu pour des communautés, de l'entraide, vraiment plein de choses formidables et en même temps,
une echo chamber, un pouvoir amplificateur très important pour la haine, pour la radicalisation, tout ça.
Est-ce que j'ai bien résumé ou est-ce que ça manque de nuances ?
Ce que je répondrais, c'est que je disais tout à l'heure que les chercheurs, on se devait d'être neutres, mais on l'est jamais totalement.
Non, c'est clair.
Et en fait, si par exemple, t'avais un autre chercheur en face de toi qui travaille sur les mêmes questions de recherche que moi, parce qu'on est heureusement plusieurs, peut-être que t'auras un discours très différent.
La vérité, c'est qu'effectivement, je suis d'accord qu'il y a des intérêts économiques qui sont présents sur ces plateformes, mais j'ai tendance en tout cas à rester de manière générale sur une vision optimiste des êtres humains.
Pas forcément de ces plateformes ou de ceux qui vont les diriger de manière générale, mais de manière générale,
est-ce que vraiment parce qu'ils veulent qu'on ait des messages, des discours haineux ou parce qu'ils nous emmènent vers là avec leur algorithme, est-ce qu'on va y aller ?
Et ça, c'est une question complexe. C'est vraiment ce que je disais tout à l'heure, le fait d'être attentif à certains contenus.
Je pense qu'on néglige la part, à quel point on façonne aussi les réseaux sociaux en tant qu'individu et que même si on nous emmène quelque part, nous aussi, on va quelque part quand on utilise ces plateformes.
Et donc, il y a beaucoup, par exemple, de stratégies qui sont mises en place par des personnes. Et ça, je trouve qu'on oublie toutes ces stratégies. Alors—
Stratégies, c'est-à-dire ?
On n'est pas, pas tout le monde est né dans les réseaux sociaux, mais il y a des générations qui commencent à être nées avec les réseaux sociaux.
Ces générations-là, et nous aussi d'ailleurs, mais ces générations-là, elles, elles utilisent pas, elles savent d'elles-mêmes se protéger de ces plateformes parce que justement, elles sont nées dedans.
Alors, stratégie, ça peut être le temps d'écran. De plus en plus, on voit des gens qui vont limiter leur temps d'écran. Donc, on peut directement le faire avec son téléphone.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut dire, par exemple, si je passe sur TikTok, on peut dire au bout de quarante minutes ou vingt minutes, je veux que l'application me mette un petit message pour me dire stop.
Et on voit de plus en plus de personnes, par exemple, qui vont utiliser ce genre de stratégie en fait, pour limiter les effets.
Ça peut être aussi des personnes qui vont bloquer des contenus qui leur sont négatifs ou qui ont l'impression qu'ils leur font du mal.
Ça peut être aussi, donc c'est plus en rapport avec les smartphones, mais il y a des personnes qui enlèvent les notifications du téléphone pour pas que ça les dérange constamment.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'on oublie aussi que nous, on n'est pas juste passifs face aux technologies. On n'est pas juste, on prend une technologie dans nos mains et hop, tout ce que la technologie veut de nous, elle l'aura.
C'est pas comme ça que ça marche. Si c'était le cas, je veux dire, ça fait déjà presque vingt ans, même vingt ans, que Facebook ou en tout cas que LinkedIn sont là.
Et je trouve qu'on s'est plutôt bien adaptés. Et on façonne aussi les plateformes. C'est-à-dire que quand je parle de normes, c'est pas vraiment les plateformes qui vont lancer ces normes.
C'est souvent les gens qui sont dessus. Twitter, il a été d'abord utilisé par le monde journalistique et c'est les personnes qui étaient sur Twitter qui ont lancé ces normes, simplement en commençant à poster, puis en répondant, etc.
Et c'est le cas pour toutes les plateformes. L'évolution de LinkedIn dont on parlait, c'est une évolution aussi qui est faite pas forcément par LinkedIn.
Alors les plateformes peuvent plus ou moins le contrer, mais par exemple, Instagram s'est fait à la base pour être basé sur de l'image, donc on s'attend à poster systématiquement des images parce qu'on est obligé.
Mais du coup, qu'est-ce que font les utilisateurs ? Des fois, ils mettent une image de texte. Et en fait, c'est ce que je voulais dire, c'est qu'on oublie,
et je dis pas que c'est faux et je peux pas dire la part de ce qui va avoir le plus de poids l'un sur l'autre.
Je peux pas dire si c'est ces créateurs qui ont leur idée en tête de ce qu'ils veulent avec leur plateforme, mais on est ingénieux et on l'est aussi sur les réseaux sociaux.
On a été ingénieux pendant tout le temps, si je peux dire ça. On n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui, on ne serait pas encore une espèce qui vivrait.
Et donc il y a un moment donné où on s'adapte aussi à ces nouvelles technologies, on les façonne et voilà. Donc j'ai une vision plutôt optimiste de manière générale de l'être humain.
Mmm-hmm.
Et dans mes recherches en tout cas, j'ai pas trouvé de choses, parce qu'on est chercheur, on essaye toujours de prouver qu'on a tort aussi.
C'est aussi le but. Et pour l'instant, y a pas de recherche qui peut clairement dire que les réseaux sociaux sont négatifs à 200 %.
Mmm-hmm. Tu
termines ta réponse en disant que tu es plutôt optimiste vis-à-vis de l'être humain de manière générale.
C'est peut-être une question un peu désagréable, mais tu as commencé ta réponse en disant : peut-être si j'avais un autre ou une autre chercheuse en face de moi, j'aurais une réponse très différente.
Et tu as parlé de la question de la neutralité.
Et du coup, cet aspect, voilà, optimiste vis-à-vis de la condition de l'être humain, est-ce que tu appellerais ça un biais dans ton travail de chercheuse ou c'est compliqué, non ?
Non, mais alors on a tous des biais hein, c'est normal. Le fait, c'est juste d'en avoir conscience. Parce que si on a conscience de ces biais, on peut dans nos recherches justement le limiter.
La semelle, oui, oui.
Voilà. Et donc en fait, c'est juste que c'est important de savoir qu'on a des biais en tant que chercheur, on a un avis en tant qu'être humain et cet avis, forcément, à un moment donné, il impacte nos recherches.
Alors quand je disais qu'un autre chercheur pourrait dire autre chose de différent, c'est pas dire dans la littérature scientifique, on a des tendances.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc ce qui veut dire qu'on a par exemple différents courants de pensée dans la littérature scientifique et que les chercheurs vont plus ou moins s'inscrire dans un courant de pensée.
Du coup, je peux les détailler comme ça, ce sera clair. On a les gens qui pensent que les réseaux sociaux, c'est très mauvais.
Donc souvent, ils se basent sur le temps d'écran et ils disent effectivement, plus on passe de temps sur les réseaux sociaux, plus, je disais, on a cet effet faible, petit, négatif, mais faible.
Donc eux, ils ont ça. Il y a des chercheurs qui disent qu'on n'a pas d'effet. Ils disent : bah cet effet faible est petit, c'est finalement trop petit pour dire qu'il y a un effet.
Donc les réseaux sociaux, il faut arrêter de dire que c'est mauvais. On sait pas, c'est pas mauvais.
Donc il y a ces chercheurs, puis c'est des chercheurs qui disent qu'en fait, on doit maintenant s'inscrire dans ce qu'on appelle un bien-être technologique où en fait, il faut inscrire un digital wellbeing,
bien-être digital plutôt, mais dans cette idée où les réseaux sociaux font déjà partie de notre sphère et au lieu de voir comment ils impacteraient notre bien-être, il faut considérer qu'ils font déjà partie de notre bien-être.
Donc je sais pas si c'est clair, mais du coup, il y a des chercheurs qui pensent que les réseaux sociaux, ça n'a aucun impact.
Et puis il y a cette troisième portion de chercheurs dans laquelle plutôt je m'inscris dans mes recherches, qui va essayer de comprendre.
Donc l'effet est petit, l'effet est négatif, mais du coup, qu'est-ce qui peut expliquer qu'il est petit
? Et donc moi, j'essaie de comprendre qu'est-ce qui fait que pour certaines personnes, les réseaux sociaux sont positifs pour eux et qu'est-ce qui fait que pour certaines personnes, il est négatif.
Et pour moi, c'est ça qui explique qu'on a du coup un effet petit. C'est parce qu'en fait, on mélange tout ensemble et que du coup, il faut pas mélanger, il faut distinguer.
Donc quand je dis que je suis optimiste, je suis optimiste dans le sens où je vais pas forcément, je vais essayer de comprendre, d'aller un peu plus loin, mais ça veut pas forcément dire que mes travaux sont biaisés pour autant.
C'est juste un courant de pensée dans lequel on s'inscrit. Dans la recherche, c'est souvent le cas.
Une tendance quoi, oui.
Mais je te félicite pour ta réponse, je trouve ça super cool. Souvent, quand j'interviewe des chercheurs, des chercheuses, je vais avoir en face de moi quelqu'un qui—
on m'a déjà demandé de couper des parties du podcast parce que je vais surtout pas afficher une opinion sur un courant de pensée ou surtout afficher une sorte de biais où tu sais, je veux avoir l'air neutre, tout ça.
Et je trouve ça très bien, le recul que tu prends en disant : bah voilà, chacun appartient à des tendances différentes et j'essaye de faire la part des choses sur base de ça.
Je trouve ça vraiment beaucoup plus intéressant que les personnes qui veulent se convaincre qu'elles sont neutres.
Après, je pense que chacun, en tant que chercheur, c'est aussi compliqué hein, de se définir en tant que chercheur et de définir sa position.
C'est très compliqué. Je comprends cette volonté de neutralité parce qu'il y a un côté rassurant derrière la neutralité.
Je pense que c'est bien en tant que chercheur, mais c'est vrai que—
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est la neutralité ?
Bah...
Est-ce que tu as lu Alice Coffin ?
Non.
Non, elle, elle dit, c'est que la neutralité, c'est le point de vue des dominants.
C'est pas faux.
Voilà.
Mais par exemple, quand je parlais des tics sur TikTok, les recherches que j'avais lues, qui étaient certes intéressantes dans la méthodologie utilisée, ils avaient un point de vue que TikTok, c'est mauvais.
Donc, ils ont basé leur étude sur ce point de vue.
Quand je dis que je suis optimiste, c'est-à-dire que moi, dans mon étude, j'aurais peut-être essayé de partir du point de vue que peut-être TikTok peut déstigmatiser la maladie mentale et d'une certaine manière peut-être la glamouriser.
Mais j'aurais essayé du coup de comprendre pourquoi aussi on peut arriver à développer ou en tout cas à se découvrir une maladie mentale alors qu'on l'avait pas,
en essayant de me renseigner sur : est-ce que c'est juste parce qu'ils ont gagné de l'information ?
Est-ce que c'est parce qu'en déstigmatisant la maladie mentale, les gens ressentent moins de honte ? C'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient déjà la maladie, ils le savaient, mais ils avaient honte de l'avoir.
Donc, et en fait, j'essaye d'avoir toutes ces hypothèses en tête et du coup, j'arrive à tester ma recherche. Alors que si j'étais dans un point de vue plutôt pessimiste, en fait, je me suffirais.
J'essaye de garder ce point de vue optimiste en me disant : effectivement, c'est des plateformes qui sont financées, mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire d'autre derrière ?
Mmm-hmm. Alors, c'est super intéressant. On a parlé de beaucoup de questions vis-à-vis donc de la question du bien-être, entre autres choses, et tout ce qui est lié.
Est-ce qu'il te reste encore un peu de temps pour parler donc de cette fameuse question du sentiment d'appartenance à l'identité européenne et la prise de parole dans le cadre des agressions sexuelles ?
On peut en parler un tout petit peu, oui.
Super, oui. Mais donc parlons alors de— commençons par la question de la prise de parole des victimes de violences sexuelles.
Tu as travaillé sur cette question. Est-ce que, de nouveau, on observe des différences en fonction de la plateforme ? Est-ce qu'on observe des différences qui font que les gens vont
Principalement des femmes, j'imagine, vont, les personnes vont choisir de s'exprimer ou de garder le silence.
Qu'est-ce que tu as pu observer ?
Alors une des choses à avoir en tête, c'est que quand on veut parler d'une violence qu'on a vécue, il y a plein de raisons différentes.
Il y a parfois des personnes qui veulent encourager les autres à le faire. Il y a des personnes qui veulent tout simplement changer la mentalité, c'est-à-dire changer la société.
Il y a des personnes qui en ont besoin pour se reconstruire. Il y a des personnes qui en ont besoin pour accepter aussi, dépasser la honte en fait, se dire : « J'ai pas à avoir honte ».
Donc en fait, il y a énormément, il y a des gens qui ont besoin de soutien aussi, des personnes qui se sentent très seules et qui ont besoin des autres en fait dans ces moments-là.
Et donc effectivement, selon les plateformes, on voit des différences. C'est vrai que dans mes recherches, on voit souvent que sur Twitter, on va avoir plus tendance à vouloir mobiliser les personnes, c'est-à-dire,
on va témoigner parce qu'on a envie d'une certaine manière de changer la perception que les autres ont de ce qu'on a vécu
et aussi encourager les autres à parler et amener un mouvement, un vrai changement dans la société.
Sur d'autres réseaux sociaux, donc par ex— on n'a pas parlé de Reddit parce que c'est vrai qu'en France, on l'utilise pas énormément.
Oui, c'est, j'crois, le sixième site le plus visité aux États-Unis, mais effectivement, dans le reste du monde, c'est un peu plus—
Exactement. Mais il y a des recherches qui sont faites du coup sur Reddit. Et en fait, donc c'est un réseau social où—
C'est très, très vieux. C'est encore plus vieux que Facebook.
Ouais, c'est, et en tout cas sur Reddit ou Instagram, on voit que les personnes qui vont témoigner vont avoir tendance plus à donner plus de détails sur ce qu'ils ont vécu et à chercher plus de soutien social.
Donc c'est pas une science exacte, hein, mais c'est vrai que selon les plateformes, on va pas y chercher la même chose et donc on va pas parler de la même chose.
Et ça, ça a le même effet en fait pour tout ce qui est témoigner d'une violence ou d'une discrimination qu'on a vécue parce qu'on va pas chercher la même chose sur chaque plateforme.
Et donc pourquoi est-ce que tu parlais spécifiquement de Reddit ?
Parce que c'est une plateforme qui a été énormément étudiée dans le cas des violences sexuelles et sexistes.
D'accord. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il y a des, alors on peut— j'suis pas une experte de Reddit, mais il y a des sous-groupes, du coup.
Des sous-Reddit.
Exactement. Et en fait, il y en a beaucoup qui sont dédiés aux violences sexuelles et sexistes où beaucoup de victimes ont tendance à parler et à...
Mais pour le coup, celui-là, il est vraiment cent pour cent inévitablement anonyme. C'est même pas vraiment possible d'afficher sa photo et d'être connu.
On a même des comptes jetables, c'est-à-dire des—
Oui, c'est ça, oui, throw away, oui, c'est ça, les gens qui se font des comptes pendant une demi-heure puis après—
Voilà donc, mais justement, il y a beaucoup de recherches qui montrent que pas mal
de personnes, parce qu'il y avait cette possibilité de compte jetable et d'anonymat, se sentaient plus à l'aise d'aller en parler sur Reddit que sur d'autres plateformes.
La différence évidente, c'est que si par exemple, on veut mobiliser et changer la société, Twitter est plutôt adapté parce qu'on a une grande visibilité, on sait que les messages vont passer vite.
Si par exemple, je poste sur Instagram, je peux avoir une grande visibilité, mais il faut déjà être un peu connu. C'est difficile, on va dire, d'avoir un post viral sur Instagram.
Ça l'est beaucoup moins sur Twitter et ça l'est encore moins maintenant sur TikTok. TikTok, c'est tout le monde peut devenir viral à un moment donné, pendant un petit moment, mais tout le monde peut devenir viral.
Et donc, l'évolution de ces plateformes change même finalement la donne, probablement de la manière dont les mouvements sociaux vont être à l'avenir, de la manière dont les victimes vont témoigner aussi.
Mais ça change même la donne en termes de qui est célèbre, qui ne l'est pas et qui peut devenir viral et qui ne l'est pas.
Donc c'est vraiment une évolution des plateformes qui questionne en fait les résultats ou les recherches qu'on avait par le passé.
Donc, tu parles de cette notion-là parce que donc c'est ça qui justifie le choix de
apparemment beaucoup de personnes, beaucoup de victimes d'agressions sexuelles pour Reddit, pour donc avoir un petit groupe de paroles plutôt isolé, plutôt anonyme,
où voilà, on va pas se retrouver à faire le buzz, à devenir une superstar
en parlant de, voilà, en partageant son témoignage.
Exactement, c'est ça. C'est qu'en fait, il y a aussi des,
des fois juste une question d'habitude ou de sensibilité à certaines plateformes, parce que quand on doit parler de quelque chose qui est aussi sensible, ben forcément, on va sur la plateforme dans laquelle on,
on se sent le plus proche, si je peux dire ça comme ça.
Les personnes, par exemple, qui témoignaient sur Facebook, c'était plus dans une optique de montrer à leur entourage quelque chose dont ils voulaient pas parler parce qu'ils savaient forcément que ça allait être vu par leur entourage.
Et donc, il y a aussi cette notion,
genre quand on poste sur Twitter, on sait que ça peut être vu par n'importe qui. Quand on poste sur Facebook, on reste dans un cadre plutôt restreint, mais dans un cadre de gens qui nous connaissent et qui peut-être n'ont jamais su.
Ben, je dirais que sur Twitter, on poste, on peut être vu effectivement par à peu près n'importe qui, même s'ils ne font pas partie de nos cercles.
Inversement, sur Facebook, on est certain que ça va être vu par
notre entourage. Et donc peut-être que ça peut faire partie d'un processus thérapeutique de se dire : « Bon ben madame Blanche, j'ai fait le choix de l'afficher, d'en parler,
non pas à des inconnus, mais à des gens qui me reprochent quoi ».
Exactement. Et puis, il faut aussi garder en tête que beaucoup, beaucoup de personnes n'en parlent juste pas. On a eu l'impression avec le mouvement MeToo que tout le monde allait sur Twitter.
C'est pas vrai, en fait. Y a— les phénomènes qui font que des personnes n'osent pas parler de ce qu'elles ont vécu, ben sont toujours d'actualité.
Ça aussi, on oublie. On croit que les réseaux sociaux, ça pousse tout le monde à juste raconter leur vie en continu.
Et en fait, c'est pas du tout le cas. C'est-à-dire que j'en ai pas parlé, mais la plupart des gens ne postent rien sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et voilà, moi, je ne poste pas tant que ça sur les réseaux sociaux. Et encore, je pense que je poste beaucoup, mais la plupart des gens ne postent rien.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose qu'on oublie aussi. On a tendance à voir les réseaux sociaux comme les gens racontent tout et n'importe quoi, ils pensent que leur parole est plus importante que celle des autres et donc ils vont poster.
Mais la vérité, c'est que la plupart des personnes ne font que lire le contenu des autres.
Ouais. Donc, on digresse un petit peu du sujet original, mais pour rester là-dessus, est-ce que ça a été étudié de savoir un petit peu les différences entre les personnes qui
se sentent vraiment à l'aise pour poster quotidiennement beaucoup de contenu ou les personnes qui, au contraire, ont plutôt envie de rester en retrait, qu'est-ce qui fait la différence entre ces profils-là ?
Alors, j'ai pas lu de recherches sur ces questions-là précisément, mais je pense qu'il y en a qui ont été faites. Donc ça vaudrait le coup de s'y pencher.
Si t'as pas de réponse, c'est pas grave.
Non.
Ok, ok. Ok, ok. Ben pas de souci. Donc, mais donc revenons donc sur la question de la prise de parole des victimes d'agressions sexuelles.
On l'a vu, voilà, les différentes plateformes qui offrent différents contextes. Et tu disais beaucoup de personnes qui, ben, prennent pas la parole parce que ça reste très compliqué.
Est-ce que les personnes qui prennent la parole, est-ce que ça a un effet thérapeutique ? Est-ce que ça a un effet vraiment de bien-être d'en parler, voilà,
que ce soit de se faire très large sur Twitter ou se faire plus restreinte sur Facebook, est-ce qu'il y a un,
oui, un effet thérapeutique ?
Ça dépend. Alors, il y a des personnes, oui, parce que ça leur a vraiment permis de raconter leur histoire avec leurs mots, donc vraiment un sentiment de dépasser la honte.
Donc il y a des personnes qui disent ça les a vraiment aidés. Y a des personnes qui, quand elles témoignaient, elles avaient déjà fait le travail avant.
C'est-à-dire que c'est des personnes qui étaient déjà au clair avec ce qu'ils avaient vécu et qui témoignaient pour encourager les autres.
Donc— Mais y a des personnes aussi qui disent qu'ils ont été revictimisés à cause des réseaux sociaux, des personnes qui ont eu des commentaires négatifs ou des situations de harcèlement qui ont suivi après leur témoignage.
Donc, en fait, de nouveau, bah, ça dépend vraiment des personnes, mais on a un peu tous les cas de figure, malheureusement.
Mmm-hmm. Et je sais pas si c'est directement lié, mais quand tu as travaillé sur la notion de,
des réseaux sociaux et de sexisme, puisque tu parlais de, voilà, de réponses négatives, de presque une forme de harcèlement par rapport aux victimes qui prennent la parole,
les notions de révélation de soi et d'action collective, est-ce que c'est pertinent dans ce cas-ci ?
Puisque ce sont des notions sur lesquelles tu as pu travailler.
Oui, alors moi, en fait... C'est plus des,
des pans de la littérature scientifique que j'ai mobilisés, mais c'est plus que,
on est vraiment, par exemple, quand je parle d'action collective, c'est le fait de vouloir changer la société, c'est le fait d'avoir un but commun,
alors que quand je parle de révélation de soi, y a plus cette idée de vouloir chercher du soutien de la part de ses proches.
Et donc du coup, c'est effectivement sur ça que j'ai travaillé, en voulant justement comprendre, en fait, si c'était plus l'un et l'autre.
Et la vérité, c'est que c'est les deux. Et que justement, en fonction de la plateforme, on peut rechercher plus l'un ou plus l'autre,
parce que certaines plateformes sont juste plus adaptées pour, comme on en a parlé, sur Reddit ou Facebook, par exemple.
Ok, ok. Autre chose sur la prise de parole des victimes d'agression sexuelle ou bien est-ce qu'on passe sur le sentiment d'identité européenne ?
Non, pour moi, c'est bon.
Ok, super. Mais parlons de sentiment de...
On n'est pas obligé d'en parler hein.
Mais si. Moi, ça m'intéresse. C'est quelque part l'idée d'étudier
la participation à la sphère politique, l'attitude par rapport à la politique, l'attitude par rapport à l'Europe sont des questions que t'as pu étudier dans tes travaux.
Donc première question, déjà, qu'est-ce qui t'a amené à travailler là-dessus et ensuite, qu'est-ce que tu as remarqué ?
Alors, quand je travaillais principalement sur l'effet des réseaux sociaux sur le bien-être, on me disait souvent : « C'est intéressant, mais est-ce qu'on n'a pas envie d'aller plus loin ?
» C'est-à-dire que les réseaux sociaux, ça impacte pas que le bien-être, ça impacte plein de pans de la vie. Et qu'est-ce qu'il en est, par exemple, de la participation politique ?
Donc c'est une question où je me suis... C'est vrai que dès que je parlais de Twitter, on allait me parler du filter bubble.
Enfin, c'était automatique, quasiment. Et donc forcément, à un moment donné, je me suis dit : « Bon, j'ai envie de me lancer aussi, j'ai envie d'essayer de comprendre ça et de chercher un peu plus loin.
» Et du coup, les recherches, en fait, c'est un peu l'inverse du bien-être. Elles montrent globalement un effet positif pour la participation politique.
Ça veut dire que plus les gens utilisent les réseaux sociaux, plus ils vont participer à la politique. Alors, participer politique, ça peut être quoi ?
Ça peut être juste parler de politique, ça peut être aller voter, ça peut être boycotter certains produits, ça peut être protester dans la rue.
Donc c'est très, très, très vaste, ce qu'on appelle par participation politique. En fait, toute la question des recherches, c'était de comprendre est-ce que ça diminue l'inégalité de participation ?
Parce que justement, il y a plein de minorités qui n'ont pas accès à la participation politique. Est-ce que justement, les réseaux sociaux, ça peut offrir une nouvelle voie ?
Et puis, il y avait aussi des débats qui disaient : « Oui, mais quand on fait de l'activisme sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est un activisme qui est pas important, qui a pas beaucoup d'impact.
» Et donc finalement, les gens vont pas aller voter par la suite. Alors, il s'avère que les recherches, donc on appelle ça le slacktivism ou le clicktivism, donc le clicktivisme,
où c'est juste, on clique, on signe une pétition et au final, voilà, ça va pas nous pousser à aller faire des actions plus tangibles ou concrètes.
Mais c'est pas le cas. C'est-à-dire que souvent, quand on voit que les réseaux... plus les gens sont sur les réseaux sociaux, plus ça les amène souvent à participer politiquement, que ce soit,
entre guillemets, hors ligne ou en ligne.
Donc hors ligne ou en ligne. Donc
c'est pas vraiment le cas. En fait, c'est pas parce qu'on participe en... Déjà, ça veut pas dire que ça n'a pas d'effet, parce que ça peut avoir un gros effet pour des personnes de témoigner sur les réseaux sociaux,
dans un but de participation politique, par exemple.
Mais voilà, dans l'idée, c'est ce que montrent ces travaux. Et de manière générale, maintenant, ce qu'on essaie de comprendre, c'est pourquoi on a cet effet positif.
Est-ce que ça dépend des personnes ? Donc c'est un peu les mêmes questions que je me pose pour le bien-être.
En fait, j'essaie de me les poser pour la participation politique. Qui utilise les réseaux sociaux ? Comment ils les utilisent ?
Quelle plateforme ils utilisent ? Et j'essaye de faire la même chose, en fait, pour ces questions-là. Mais voilà, j'ai commencé ces travaux très récemment, donc j'ai pas forcément autant de recul.
Tu n'as pas encore de réponses. Tu peux pas encore me dire si l'opinion politique, les positions politiques sont impactées par les réseaux sociaux.
Alors, on a quand même des recherches qui montrent que, de manière générale, les réseaux sociaux ont un effet sur la polarisation, donc le fait qu'on aille plus vers les extrêmes.
Et oui, un effet plutôt, si on peut dire, donc négatif, c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas forcément de nuances par rapport aux aspects que j'ai évoqués précédemment, mais les recherches montrent clairement que ça peut amener à plus de polarisation.
Ok. Et donc sur la fameuse notion d'identité européenne, qu'est-ce que tu as pu observer ?
Ah, c'est très nouveau, mais la question, c'est : est-ce que finalement... Parce qu'être européen, c'est quelque chose de très compliqué.
On l'est tous, mais on se sent pas forcément européen. On le voit pas tous les jours au quotidien qu'on est européen.
Et la question, c'est : est-ce que les réseaux sociaux, ça peut nous permettre, d'une certaine manière, eh ben, de nous rappeler notre côté européen ?
Parce que c'est transnational, les réseaux sociaux, donc y a un côté aussi plus global. Les recherches, elles montrent plutôt que oui, mais y a très peu de recherches dessus.
Et pourquoi ? En fait, souvent parce que c'est des gens qui ont voyagé. Ce qui fait qu'on se sent européen, c'est souvent quand on a voyagé en Europe.
Les Erasmus.
Exactement.
Les voyages d'affaires, les vacances.
Exactement. C'est souvent les personnes qui voyagent le plus qui se sentent le plus européen. Pas que, mais voilà.
Et du coup, les réseaux sociaux,
ça permet des fois à ces personnes de rester connectées avec des personnes qu'ils ont rencontrées
à l'autre bout de l'Europe, des personnes qui reverront peut-être qu'une ou deux fois dans leur vie, et ça peut impacter leur sentiment de se sentir européen.
Donc pour l'instant, c'est là où on en est dans les recherches.
Du coup, je comprends pourquoi tu me disais qu'on n'était pas obligé d'en parler. C'est parce qu'il reste encore beaucoup de questions.
Il reste encore beaucoup de questions et tu peux pas nous exploser la cervelle en nous révélant des choses sur le futur de politique en Europe.
Très bien, mais on a parlé de beaucoup de choses. C'était super intéressant. Tu connais ton sujet, ça, c'est clair.
Est-ce qu'il y a une dernière chose que tu voudrais rajouter avant de se quitter ?
Non. Ben merci beaucoup pour l'invitation.
Merci à toi d'être d'offre le voyage depuis Maastricht, du coup. Et je te souhaite un bon voyage de retour. Et on se dit à dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode.
Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode avec Alexandra Masciantonio. J'espère que ça vous a plu. J'espère que mon addiction à TikTok ne s'est pas trop vue.
Vous pouvez suivre Alexandra sur tous les réseaux sociaux. Vous aurez compris que, voilà, elle aime bien ça. Et voilà, comme je vous l'expliquais, je sors tous les épisodes de mon backlog en une seule fois, après beaucoup trop de retard accumulé,
avant les vacances.
Et y a donc deux autres épisodes à aller écouter, un premier sur les applications de rencontre et le tout dernier épisode de cette saison avec le docteur Pierre Oswald, psychiatre et confrère podcasteur.
On a parlé ensemble de paraphilie. J'ai trouvé ça vraiment super intéressant. Je fais aussi quelques annonces à la fin de cet épisode-là, donc surtout, ne passez pas à côté.
Je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut !